foreign
dear colleagues today's key debate is on
Russia's escalation of its war of
aggression against Ukraine
on the 30th of September after Russia
staged a series of sham referenda it
illegally annexed the occupied
territories of Ukraine and what is a
blatant violation of Ukraine sovereignty
territorial integrity and international
law
so on behalf of the European Parliament
let me reiterate
Donetsk herzon luhansk and zaporiza just
like Crimea are and will remain part of
independent and Sovereign Ukraine
and no sham referenda can ever change
this
so it is uh my pleasure to now give the
floor on behalf of the council
to Joseph Burrell just open the debate
after which we give the floor the
president of the commission holds love
on their line so we're only on the floor
good morning I'm going to speak in
Spanish
in Europe
presidents
vice president
honorable members
I'm speaking in this plenary in
representation of the council
of the European Union
in order to explain to you
that since together with the commission
the high rep sensitive we
set out a new set of
General and personal sanctions co-repair
and ambassadors have been working hard
on this last night they were working and
the meeting is continuing this morning
and I trust that before the end of this
cleaner resetting we will have reached
an agreement within the council
and the adoption of the joint proposal
put forward by the commission
and
I've no doubt that the president
will give you the details I'd like to
thank the president of the commission
and my colleagues for the efforts and
the leadership that they've shown
in continuing to come forward with
proposals and debating proposals for
sexual assactions together with the
targeted personal sanctions
this should further constrain Russia's
export capacity
and the relations it's interesting to
continue to carry out particularly the
technological sector
linked to the wall
in August of last year
we were importing 12
billion cubic liters only four
this year we we've cut our imports from
I said to a third of what they were
over the last 36 weeks
we've reduced Imports by 54 billion
and give it meters that's going to allow
us to reduce our energy dependency on
Russia
which severely constrained our foreign
policy towards Russia
and as a result of that impact on our
foreign policy including Ukraine
we needed a foreign policy
towards Ukraine it had been
subjects to our policy with Russia and
that in turn had been subject to our
energy dependency but now we have a
clear policy towards Ukraine
informed by our will to ensure that
Ukraine go on to join the European Union
there's a clear goal behind this policy
this will become possible because we
will no longer be so dependent on Russia
there's good news on the battlefield for
Ukraine in the warm Ukraine
is going back onto the offensive
the war has entered a new phase
it's undoubtedly a dangerous phase
because we're in a terrible scenario now
we mustn't cut our eyes to this
there's a scenario of a conventional
wall
involving a nuclear power which is
currently retreating
from the conventional theater but
threatening to deploy nuclear weapons
this scenario is undoubtedly a source of
concern
and we have to show that our support for
Ukraine is not weakening
Ukraine is making progress on three
fronts in the donbass having retaken Lee
man
and this this Center and the south south
of zaporation advancing towards Mario
Paul
and lastly in Herson
Russia still has numerical superiority
and it still has Superior Firepower and
that's why you create Union forces
are using extremely agile tactics
they're using very powerful intelligence
surrounding uh
concentrations Russian power creating
Pockets which
are then destroyed as the Russian army
itself withdraws this allows the Ukraine
forces to to keep their losses lower
than they would have been and score
successes that no one would earlier have
forecast
the situation for us is extremely
powerless
Russian soldiers for one thing don't
actually know the purpose of this war
the 300 000 men who are going to be
taken from their homes and sent to the
front
will understand it even less
so
you can win a war on the battlefield
but first and foremost you have to win
it
under the battlefield of ideas because
behind the war as such there's war as a
struggle for supremacy of values Russia
is fighting hard around the world
to make the case that the the
consequences of this war
are actually the result of our sanctions
against Russia
we have to fight that battle in talks
with our colleagues all around the world
we must continue to isolate to Russia
a very important in international body
and the icao
um
recently and we we need to keep up this
effort consistently because
there are a lot of strong feelings
around the world regarding the causes of
this war and above all its consequences
for many countries the consequences of
the war are undoubtedly bad ones
increasing energy and food costs
we have to make a strong commitment to
the rest of the world to provide them
with assistance to help them overcome
the impact of this war
we'll have to make a huge diplomatic
effort to explain the case
so that the world will understand why it
is
that this war's coming Fountain and how
it may end
it cannot end because the world the
Western World becomes exhausted that's
what Putin is hoping will happen he
thinks that democracies are weak
that systems of public opinion he thinks
put up with it a cold war he's waiting
for General winter to come along which
has always helped
Russia win previous conflicts he's
hoping that the the cold
and the the cut in gas supplies and high
energy prices low temperatures
will undermine our will to continue our
support to Ukraine and this is the place
where I have to ask Europeans to
understand what's going on
our support for Ukraine isn't just a
question of generosity our support for
Ukraine
has to remain total because Ukraine's
weight is intimately bound up with our
own
what happens there
entails our future too
he has honorable members
decisions there determine our future too
and that's why it's so important to
ensure that just as others have done in
Europe
for going on previous Imperial Ambitions
Russia also needs to give up its
Imperial ambitions
we need to work in a way to ensure that
there's peace and that means that
Ukraine
must recover its territorial integrity
and its full sovereignty
Russia must shoulder its political and
moral responsibilities in the war
let's pay for the reconstruction
and those responsible for crimes against
humanity committed there must be brought
to account
that must be our goal and so we have our
sanctions and we're providing our nurse
resistance and we're taking diplomatic
action on those three fronts we must
continue to redouble our efforts
unflaggingly this is not the time for
doubt European Society must be able to
keep up this struggle supporting Ukraine
using the procedures we have available
to us the president of the commission
today will be presenting the details of
the sanctions package that the council
will be adopting but above and beyond
specific sanctions
the really important thing is for
Europeans to grasp that if there's a
price to be paid that price is worth it
because if we don't pay this price we
will end up paying a much higher price
later
this is a battle for freedom
for ukrainians but also for our freedom
and the effort we have to make will be
written into history books as appointed
industry where a United Europe
proved able to resist the aggression
are for radically different to political
organization from our own thank you
thank you
Steve
next I give the floor commission
president Russell love on the line
please
thank you president Roberta
Minister HIV pedia Joseph honorable
members
it's just four weeks ago that we met
here in the Hemi cycle
for the State of the Union but in those
four weeks the Kremlin has escalated its
aggression to a new level
Putin has launched Russia's first
mobilization since World War II
treating hundreds of thousands of young
Russians as Canon fodder he uses sham
referendum in an illegal attempt to
change International borders by force
and since many months he is using energy
as a weapon
now of course we feel that the Russian
war causes economic and social hardship
and it places a heavy burden on our
citizens and on the economy in our
single Market we see in particular the
rising Energy prices and gas and
electricity prices that are leading to
reduced purchasing power and they are
leading to a loss of competitiveness for
our business in the international market
but our resilience
in all these difficult times is
remarkable
and what we have to do is work steadily
on our resilience
mainly on the field of energy and that's
where I want to focus on today
if you look at the course of this last
seven months together with our member
states we have already taken important
steps
we have diminished our gas consumption
by around 10 that's good it's not enough
we have to do more but it's a big step
forward
I want to give you two figures what the
Russian supplies of gas are concerned at
the beginning of the war if you look at
all the Imports of gas
Russian the Russian share was 41 percent
within seven months we have gone down to
7.5 that's good and we have compensated
this decrease in Russian supplies by a
massive increase by our trusted
suppliers for example the United States
for example Norway
let's look at gas storage it is almost
at 90 percent by now
this is 15 higher than on the same day
last year
three weeks ago in this semicycle
I announced that we will skim the
exceptional profits that electricity
producing companies have these days to
make them available for member states to
support vulnerable citizens and
businesses
now last week already we haven't shrined
that in law EU law we achieved that
enlightened speak and I really want to
thank the Czech presidency for this
outstanding deliverable in really a very
very short time and yesterday
the council reached agreement on repower
EU
so we will have key instruments in place
to make it through the winter that's
storage and saving to jointly purchase
gas this is our platform
to get rid of the grip the Russians have
on us through their fossil fuels
these are our agreements with other
friends
to redistribute the windfall profits to
support those in need and to invest in
the future of a sustainable energy
Supply and that is repower EU
the measures we have put in place
provide us with a first buffer of
protection and thanks to these
we can and we will now step up to the
next level
I will lay out a road map in a letter to
leaders in view of our meeting in Prague
in two days this week
and I want to discuss with you firsthand
the key components of this letter
of course it's all about energy prices
so we will step up our negotiations with
trusted partners for example with
Norway's to dampen the price we pay for
gas Imports
the talks have already started
I think as a European Union we have a
considerable Market power
and many of our suppliers want to
conclude deals with us which are
beneficial for two sides both sides so I
really think it is necessary that we
come to an agreed Corridor of Crisis to
stop this crazy Peaks we have partially
in the import of gas prices
we will strengthen our energy platform
and he let let me be very clear it is in
our Collective interest
after the winter we will have to refill
the gas storages and if we then see that
we have again a scenario where member
states are outbidding each other on the
global market and that's Rising the
prices here in the European Union this
is not sustainable so we have to have a
joint procurement of all member states
this is much better than the way we have
it
my next point is on gas prices
and as you know we use gas in three
different domains for industry
for heating and for the production of
electricity
let me start with the electricity
our market for electricity is built in a
way
that high gas prices are driving
electricity prices
we have now to limit this inflationary
impact of gas on electricity and
everywhere in Europe
this is why
we are ready to discuss a cup
on the price of gas that is used to
generate electricity
this cap would also be a first step on
the way to a structural reform an
overall reform of our electricity Market
but I think we also have to have a look
at gas prices beyond the electricity
market so where industry is concerned
where heating is also concerned the
general approach of gas
and here we will work together with
member states to reduce gas prices and
to limit volatility and thus to limit
the impact of price manipulation by
Russia because if you look at the fever
curve of gas and gas prices the whole
gas price you can see the manipulation
that Russia has on the gas prices and
this has to stop
we have already
offered this mechanism in March
at that time we've said that it can give
an important signal
that you will not pay any price for gas
anymore
we have qualified such a price cap as
having an immediate impact on price
levels but
that it entails drawbacks in terms of
security of supply
this is still true today so it's a fine
line to walk it's not trivial to do that
but the situation since March has
critically evolved since then and today
compared to March
member states are open now for it more
member states are open for it and we are
better prepared
such a cap on gas prices must be
designed properly to ensure security of
supply
and it is a temporary solution to cater
for the fact
that the ttf that is our main price
Benchmark is no longer representative
for our Market
this ttf Benchmark reflects or mirrors a
lot pipeline guns but in the last seven
months we have because we wanted to get
rid of the dependency on Russian gas we
have increased a lot the LNG market and
this LNG Market is not probably
reflected in the ttf
so introducing a cap
on gas overall is a temporary solution
until we will have a new EU Price Index
developed that ensures a better
functioning of the market and the
commission has already started to work
on this
honorable members these are far-reaching
measures
and I wholeheartedly agree with you
when you say in the the resolution you
will vote on today
that exceptional times require
exceptional measures where the union
needs to act as jointly and as United as
ever
in pursuing our action two same things
remain Paramount that is action and
unity
and action and solidarity
if I look at our single Market we really
need to protect the fundamentals of our
economy and in particular our single
Market
the single Market is the strength of our
European Union
and this is where the wealth of the
European Union comes from
without a common European solution we
risk fragmentation if every member State
goes on its own we have fragmentation we
don't want and we have to do something
against it
foreign
and therefore it is so Paramount
that we preserve a Level Playing Field
within the European Union in our single
Market ever member state is benefiting
from it as I said the wealth comes from
our single Market
now what does that mean with re-power
issue
we have developed a crucial instrument
to accelerate the transition in the
energy Independence that's what we're
working on since seven months
and we power EU will allow it's the
governance structure it will allow the
investment in infrastructure for example
pipelines for example interconnectors
for example Renewables
but it also allows and that's important
to support businesses or households to
invest in Energy Efficiency for example
insulating houses or installing heat
pumps or installing new technology for
the companies the businesses that have
to do the transition
now here's my proposal
I think we should further boost we power
EU with additional funding common
European funding
this way
All European states can accelerate the
necessary investment All European member
states
we modernize our infrastructure the
energy infrastructure
we preserve the Level Playing Field and
we secure our European competitiveness
on the global market
so we have to do this investment we have
to do this funding together as Europeans
jointly with a common solution
[Applause]
to speak about another pressing issue
which we have to address today
the acts of sabotage against North
stream Pipelines
have shown how vulnerable our energy
infrastructure is
for the first time in recent history it
has become a Target
pipelines and underwater cables connect
European citizens and companies to the
world they are the lifeline of data and
energy
it is in the interest of all Europeans
to better protect this critical
infrastructure
and for this I will present a five point
plan
first we must be better prepared
we have very recently agreed new
legislation that's good which will
strengthen the resilience of critical EU
entities
the responsible Parliament committee
will be voting on it next week that's
good too so we are absolutely on time
and I think we can and we should already
now work be working on this basis
second
we need to stress test our
infrastructure
we don't have to wait till something
happens but we need to make sure that we
are prepared and therefore we need those
stress tests
we need to identify whether we have weak
points and where these weak points are
and of course we have to prepare our
reaction to sudden disruption what are
we doing then are all the information
chains in place is everybody informed
does this
emergency scenario really work then in
our single Market
we will work with member states to
ensure effective stress tests in the
energy sector
and this then should be followed by
other high-risk sectors such as the
offshore digital
and the electricity infrastructure
my third point
we will increase our capacity
to respond through our civil protection
mechanism well known to you in the
European Union
with this we can support member states
in addressing the disruption of critical
infrastructure for example with fuel
with generators with necessary shelter
capacity
my first point we will make best use of
our satellite surveillance capacity we
have these satellites in place we have
the capacity to do the surveillance to
detect potential threats so this is also
a matter of prevention and awareness and
finally
we will strengthen our cooperation with
NATO
and with key Partners like the United
States on this critical issue
honorable members
this warm
has entered in a new phase
the Ukrainian Army keeps reporting
impressive successes in its fight
against the aggressor
we all saw the images of deeply relieved
people welcoming Ukrainian soldiers
and I could see with my own eyes when I
was three weeks ago in Kiev that life
has come back to Kiev
The Bravery of the Ukrainian people that
made it possible
but I think Europe's contribution also
has made a huge difference and now it's
the time to keep track to help the
ukrainians to Face Down The Invader as
strong as steadfast Europe that will
only be the only way to stop putting
this is the moment to stay the course
and to signal again to our Ukrainian
fans we stay by your side as long as it
takes thank you and Long Live Europe
thank you very much
commission president I give the floor
now to the leaders of the political
group starting with the Epp group
Manfred Weber
Madam president of the parliament the
European commission our representative
Minister dear colleagues
more than 220 days have passed since
Putin started his in Beijing in Ukraine
on 24th of February
more than 220 days of tremendous
suffering Bloodshed and destruction of
Ukraine people and the whole country
by end of last months we will see 13
million people fleeing Ukraine crossing
the borders to the neighboring countries
six thousand Ukraine ukrainians
died
379 children lost their life in the
Russian war
Putin is a war criminal in this all wall
criminals he doesn't stop
but not the weapons or money are winning
a war
people the will of people the
determination of people and most of all
free people defending their freedom are
winning a war as Europeans we only can
admire what the Ukraine troops are doing
every day in liman in chesson in
congratulations to president zelenski
and the Ukraine troops you're great
and obviously
and obviously even among the autocrats
of this world Russia is losing ground we
saw this in pharmacand where even the
prime minister of India Modi said
publicly it's not the right moment to go
to bore
fake referenda in occupied Ukraine
territories mobilizing now 300 000
Direction with Elizabeth and threatening
to US nuclear weapons this is obviously
a signal of weakness so the ukrainians
are doing their job
and Europe
first of all the upcoming winter is a
big test for us and we have to win it
first of all we have to be strong
against the populists inside of the
European Union just look to Marine Le
Pen and the presidential election race
this year she proposed to seek an
alliance with Russia without fear of U.S
sanctions back in 2014 fron Arsenal
found no better supporter than Russian
Banks to finance its campaign anyone
dear friends who loves his country would
never ask for money from Putin that is
what Le Pen is doing
their colleagues in Spain just after the
start of the war podemos stated that the
heart of Ukraine conflict lies in the
NATO policy of enlargement towards
Eastern Europe unbelievable lies or in
Slovakia the former president and party
leader Robert fitzo from smear party
described the war as a conflict between
the United States and Russia he called
the strengthening of NATO forces in
Slovakia by German soldiers the
welcoming of the Vermont in our country
there is a wording of leaders in Europe
of today and these populist dear friends
have only one idea they have the idea to
weaken Europe and we have to stand up to
defend Europe no more than ever it's
time now to show that we are standing
together and the Epp will never accept
to rewrite the history
our Epp parties in Finland and Sweden
for example fought always argued always
for NATO membership only recently
socialists changed their mind and also
supported NATO membership of Sweden and
Finland NATO defends freedom and peace
and Security in Europe and Putin wants
to destroy our Europe and that's why
again we have to show Unity
at the same time
at the same time
Putin's threatens must not determine now
our actions that's why we have to
support our ukrian friends more than
ever before
now more than ever before it's time for
European leadership without weapons from
the West Putin would have won long ago
already Ukraine
urgently needs more weapon including
tanks and there I ask France and Germany
to to lead Europe and to present a
proposal to deliver all the tanks we
support another action package of
sanctions and financial assistance to
Ukraine and if we want this war to end
we need actions but not any more excuses
Europe needs leadership
and now more than ever before it's time
for this winter of solidarity our on
Friday the European Council must find a
comment and understanding on the energy
solidarity in Madame commission
President we fully support your
initiatives in this field uh
continuation of uncertainty costs each
and every European money uncertainty is
driving speculation on the market so we
need a binding solidarity mechanism we
need common procurement and we need a
price cap as proposed by the commission
and we need this now this Clarity and
let me all do that because on Thursday
we have this first meeting of the
political union president erdogan will
be there and let me also underline did
we should not forget next to the Ukraine
war that we have other challenges in our
neighborhood I think that someone who is
not practicing our solidarity with
Ukraine in the same way who is not
implementing the same sanctions in a way
like we do as Europeans cannot be a
candidate status for the European Union
cannot be a reliable partner for us
that's why I hope that we also have a
clear wording towards president erdogan
that he has to show his European
commitment
with Putin escalating the war it's now
even more time to firmly stand by
Ukraine vs Epp we always did so and we
always will do so now more than ever
before without a free Ukraine there will
be not a fully free Europe thank you so
much
thank you Mr Webber
I now give the floor on behalf of the
snd group to erase Garcia Perez
gracias president thank you president
is from The Lion I'm representative
Mr
in recent days the world has seen
further Rush crazy actions by my Putin
the mobilization
and dangerous rhetoric regarding the use
of nuclear weapons
but also for the first time there have
been serious
worrying events occurring outside
Ukrainian territory and here I'm
referring to the sabotage of energy
infrastructure in the Baltic Sea
the world is following this escalation
with apprehension
a civil Convoy was attacked by Russian
forces near zapore Asia last week with
fatalities and injuries
turns out that this is the the reality
of
Putin's War Machine it's a it's a cruel
war against the civilian population of
Ukraine civilians are dying
being displaced they've had to leave
their homes fleeing atrocities last
week's annexation by
Putin is illegal and a clear violation
of the UN Charter
similarly
changing Ukraine's borders Union
naturally
without any proper checks on this is
nothing more than propaganda it shows
what Putin is a desperate man whose
leadership and Authority are more in
doubt every day this dangerous
escalation must lead us to give further
support to Ukraine and its citizens we
must step up our support
to keep Russia's dangerous Accents in
check and we need extra sanctions to
bring an end to this war
so that Putin will end up where he
belongs before the international
tribunal in The Hague and so we need to
keep up a united front in our response
that means we have to isolate as much as
possibly can those European leaders
who flirt with Putin of course they do
exist in my political family we're
extremely concerned we know about
orban's isolated position on sanctions
towards Russia
but trying to weave an alliance with
Maloney poses a problem that may lead
all of us towards a very worrying shift
we know about the cooperation between
salvini's League party in Putin
and we're worried about berlusconi's
comments to the effect that Putin wanted
to replace jelenski with good decent
people that's what Berlusconi said
is that what we must expect from the new
Italian government
as far as that goes our colleagues in
the European
The People's Party need to do something
because Putin's going to keep up his
efforts to divide us and the greater the
threats
the greater the need for Unity in our
political action Mr Weber
we need political responsibility from
you at this time
there has to be an understanding
that the real Alliance we need is with
those who defend European values I can
understand that you are in a situation
now
where it's hard for you to grasp the
real state of play but quite frankly
outside here
a lot of people are extremely concerned
by what's going on
and above and beyond the election
tactics that anyone may have
what we need is to stick to the path of
those of us who are defending the
European project some of us have have
stayed on on the spot right from the
beginning here we've been defending
Europe for European values
and I'm extending behind a friendship to
you so that you can continue on this
path together
I give the floor next on behalf of the
renew Europe group to Petra's house
president president of the commission by
representative ministers
dear colleagues
it's probably time to end up our empty
and significant disagreements and to
focus on real things on things which
shape present world and our future
Putin who claims to be the ruler of the
world
wanted to conquer Ukraine and enslave
its people in three days
not only has he failed but it has turned
into continuation of the atrocious
crimes
Against Humanity and this shameful
defeats
incurred on the Russian aggressor
realizing his impotence in the face of
the heroic Ukraine
its resistance and Nationwide
mobilization
Putin has resorted to the tool of
annexation of temporarily occupied
Ukrainian territories in order to create
a situation of a permanent War
it is
as the state of terrorism acts in
today's politics and I call Russia
state which supports and implements a
policy of terrorism
the Civilized world must respond to
Russia's colonial war aggression even
the strongest sanctions and increased
support for Ukraine
a Russian policy also demonstrates a
turning point from adherence to the
international law-based order
to the outside world it became
opportunistic and unpredictable
and domestically resulted into a deep
moral and social degradation of the
Russian state
it is a high time to realize
that our trade Western trade
and our economic relations
with a Russian aggressor is not an
option
it must discontinue
in this extraordinary circumstances
dear colleagues Ukraine needs security
guarantees now
not in a distant future
now is the time for Ukraine
when its face to be decided and
well-being of Ukrainian people are at
stake
it's time when European security is
challenged
and to be decided for next decades
NATO membership of Ukraine is the
solution
and we need to re-up its benefits now as
soon as possible through additional
formats of cooperation and Partnerships
Longleaf Europe and slavo cleaning thank
you for your attention
half of the green Sergey lagodinsky
for long enough we've heard these
statements of solidarity with Ukraine
and the ukrainians these over hasty
pseudo-referendums in occupied
territories and the mobilization of the
Russian population the Putin said he
never actually wanted show quite clearly
that Putin doesn't understand the fancy
words in these speeches he only
understands the Resolute sound of
speeches
and acts
let's not regret what's happening let's
go to court let's not talk about the
unconventional
professions of regret about what's
happening to the Ukrainian population
let us provide the concrete support of
weapons that ukrainians need
hence I'm not going to hold a fancy
speech here others have done that in my
stead maybe just picking up on a few
points out of the resolution that we
have adopted firstly and most
importantly
making sure
that the
incorporation of of
the regions that have been occupied into
the country is not acceptable these
occupied territories remain occupied
territories a war of Liberation remains
a war of Liberation and the ukrainians
remain ukrainians
in the borders that exist that are
theirs including the eastern border in
those regions of saparichia Donetsk
luhansk Hassan and right to the southern
point of Crimea that is reality and
that's how it should stay
secondly the individual sanctions need
to be extended and I would call on the
council on the commission here make sure
that the people who are reigning there
those in the regional parliaments those
in the Duma should all be put on the
list anybody in the Duma party should be
on that list they're the ones who are
who are pursuing War they're the ones
who supporting Putin and the war they
have to be put on that list
sadly the security of our own
infrastructure is not a toy we shouldn't
see that 100 of our data which is
traveling around the world is just being
uh
monitored if you like by a few ships
we're in the middle of an attack
an attack on us that is actually
happened we need to be prepared for that
and finally uh resilience and resolution
for the coming months will be tested
and it will be decisive on how this
confrontation will end up we are in a
confrontation we're not going to be
divided by this aggression and we
shouldn't be divided either by economic
attacks
we know that certain countries are
carrying out various sanctions but we
need a europeanization if you like of
this whole effort we need a green
oriented effort that is European in
nature yes individual states can press
on press ahead but we have to complement
that with European measures that's the
only way that we can win this
confrontation ski and next on behalf of
the ID group Marco
laughs
grazie
thank you president
I'm sorry that once again
I have to take some time
from my speaking time to respond to
those who are using
this opportunity for their own ends the
Socialist Group which doesn't accept the
results of elections and ignore the far
what the the far left is doing and
then we see those who are
hosting the big lobbyists we see what
the former Chancellor Schroeder is doing
and we see
those just ignoring what is being done
because it's being done by socialists so
of course Italy after the elections will
be a positive player in support to
Ukraine
I've listened carefully to what was said
by President Van Der Lyon and the high
representative
but we are very concerned
it
seems that the clock has gone back the
clock of History
if we look back
to February once again we have a war in
Europe
we're going back to the situation more
than 70 years ago a catastrophe in
history and we're facing a nuclear
threat an escalation the threat of a
cold war things we hoped we had left
behind us
but they are back again in fourth and
Europe needs to show Unity as it has
done over the last few months to stop
these threats becoming a reality the
high representative talked about the new
sanctions package and I think here the
European institutions have shown Unity
leadership pragmatism and realism
which was required and we need to make
sure that there is still major support
for those measures but as has already
been said
in parallel to that Europe needs to come
up with support measures for businesses
and families we need strong support for
the ukrainians when fighting this war
but we shouldn't
let the burden weigh on our citizens I
do share the optimism you voiced
that the winter will be relatively calm
we have all the instruments needed to
get through this winter unscathed
but
we really need support measures and I
put out an appeal here
I'm glad to hear
that there will be progress on the price
cap
we know how difficult it is to reach an
agreement we know that it will not be
easy to impose a price cap on imports
from Russia but over the last few months
these citizens have been
asking
certain things
we've seen support for NATO by the EU
but it seems that the Allies haven't
shared the burden of the measures we
know that the alloy allies have provided
support when it comes to gas supplies to
the EU
but
with those allies we have been on a
journey and we need strong support for
Europe Norway the United States Canada
all these countries are NATO members
and they are earning
six or seven times more with the
supplies to Europe so I think we should
encourage the Allies to consider their
own price cap particularly when it comes
to the next few months we need all
necessary support possibly this will
involve reduction in profit margins to
make sure that Europe can support the
approach of the West and NATO to Ukraine
thank you of the ECR group
foreign
vice president
thanks to death and
the the Fantastic
resistance of Ukrainian Army and people
and facing humiliating defeat in his war
waged against Ukraine Vladimir Putin and
Russian institution committed a series
of fatal mistakes
uh but he also renewed his nuclear
threats
against the collective West not only
against Ukraine my appeal here from this
chamber to to Western media and to
individual politicians is
to refrain from plain Putin's game
from from repeating about threats of
nuclear war
the proper action to be taken within the
collective West is to revise the nuclear
deterrence
schemes
and make Putin and Russian Elites
sure that any strike against Ukraine
Ukraine's neighbors or any Ally and EU
member states a state as well
is to be fatal for him
and his country
there is no place in contemporary world
for this kind of state terrorism thank
you
I give the floor next to Martin sure the
one on behalf of the left group
thank you very much Madam president
this war has to be Ended as soon as
possible
Russians are legal annexation parts of
Ukraine partial mobilization and the
threats of the use of nuclear weapons
have constituted a massive escalation of
this conflict
Putin is playing with fire
he is drawing in more and more innocent
people who are going to be led to their
deaths if this damn war is not ended as
soon as possible
that's why we're asking for an end to
this war of aggression by Russia and a
withdrawal of Russian troops from
Ukraine
and yes targeted sanctions against the
military and other apparatus are
quite affected effective I was in trade
recently
misunderline there were hundreds of
people there and we heard that the
people in this region are
scared
and they are waiting for decisions to be
taken because there are decisions being
taken that are not going to pertain to
the industrial future of their area it's
about what has changed in their real
lives and what they need to survive in a
day-to-day basis and whoever wants
freedom
you have to talk about diplomacy and
what we hear from the commission here
again today or representatives of
individual governments including that of
Germany have been saying I'm just
wondering if anybody really understands
diplomacy and negotiation to end this
war as soon as possible is anybody
interested in that at all
apart from further sanctions further
deliveries of weapons nobody seems to
have come up with anything even the pope
a few days ago
called on other politicians to push for
dialogue to end this war
European politics has an obligation to
stop this spiral of escalation we have
to finally sit down and contribute to
peace to end this terrible War
and of course our solidarity goes out to
the ukrainians uh solidarity goes to
that those populations who are suffering
and as harsh as this attack of Russia is
on the land and the populations
diplomatic channels have to be kept open
yes Putin is a terrible warmonger
but we cannot
punish the Russian population because of
that we have to show solidarity to those
Russians who want to oppose the war
people who's subject to the partial
mobilization has led to a flood of
people trying to cross borders to leave
these people who are working actively
against war and four peace should not
see the EU turn their backs on them they
shouldn't be
arrested and sent back yeah
[Applause]
thank you madam president
day colleagues
there's no doubt about the
regime in Ukraine and what's happening
if we look at the roots of the conflict
it was Putin who decided to invade
and
I think those wanting this to end need
to take account of the responsibility of
the U.N France and Germany in getting
the Minsk agreements complied with
and
accepting the
Us's extreme position now we see the new
set of sanctions being introduced by the
commission so it's
and these effects have not been approved
we see what's going on with regard to
Azerbaijan and Armenia we see the double
standards our objective isn't to be a
part of the conflict
and we
what what is in the interests of Europe
is to have a ceasefire
and you will have to give an account
um Madam president to the citizens of
Europe
for president
Madam president ladies and gentlemen
in a systemic conflict between uh
democracies living in peace and a
war-mongering dictator
in recent weeks we've seen and once
again escalation
and this deeply fascist aggressor has
been carrying out activities
to try and
Annex territories and Carry Out
referendums
pretending that these people are just
waiting for Russia to bring them home
but these potemkin's Villages are
facades which will fall
now it's a question of making Ukraine
fit for the winter
and we need to look at confirming the
delivery of arms yes unfortunately it's
necessary the American land lease act is
something I'd like to see here in Europe
at least in a number of member states
that would speed up deliveries of
weapons because it would make the
individual approvals
otos and I think Germany and France have
to come with their contribution Europe
has to unite on this we have to have a
comparable
contribution of weapons that we are
already seeing in eastern member states
we kind of have people going alone we
have coordinated deliveries of Tanks
leopard tanks for example and that's
something that the foreign secretary or
the chair of the Foreign Affairs
Committee in the German Parliament is
doing
how much Schmidt comes from Hamburg he
did the right thing uh the NATO dual
decision is something that he decided on
against the interests of certain people
but it served history don't be scared of
your own party approve the mother and
leopard tanks deliveries history will
prove you right for a minute
thank you
everybody gets near a president
thank you president I'm representative
president of the commission Minister
colleagues
another month has gone by in Russia's
war of regression on Ukraine as the the
president of the commission said this
has not been any ordinary month it's
been a month of
heroic reconquest of territory by the
Ukrainian forces but also
there's more annexation of regions
occupied by Putin's forces that just
shows what sort of democratic model he
has in mind voting with a gun to your
head is actually an attack on democracy
the annexation of Ukrainian territory is
a moral and illegal in the eyes of
international law no one will be able to
support that sort of action Ukraine is
entitled to defend itself and we
Europeans have the moral duty to support
history
will severely judge anyone who stands by
Putin
trying to destroy the unity
of the European Union
but the foreign writers capable of doing
this out of pure thirst for power we
have to be decisive in our action
first of all we have to provide
political economic and Military Support
to the ukrainians but we also need more
sanctions
on the Russian economy and its War
Machine we must
you can finally stop buying energy from
Russia squeezing out the oligarchs and
working to rebuild Ukraine let's not
forget that here in Europe
all Europeans who are suffering the
consequences that will also need support
in the nhsd and gas markets we need to
fight speculation and bring down prices
calling for immediate action from the
institutions
we have to be resoluting our support for
Ukraine there has to be a truly United
European response
not just those
who are at least able to support we have
to support European families to show
European solidarity
so that we can all continue to support
those who are fighting this wall for
freedom and what we didn't seek but one
that we have to win thank you for one
and a half minutes
[Applause]
no one can ignore what the Russian
people want that they've decided to make
the Ukrainian people suffer and to be
hostile from now on
the world
has everything to gain
if the Russians win there will be no
Ukraine left
so I say stop
attacking
Ukraine Ukraine does not wish to attack
Russia celinsky never talked about at
de-nutsifying the Kremlin you have
nothing to win and everything to lose
from this terrible
war and these sham referenda and I say I
say that to the Ukrainian to the
Russians and I say to the Europeans it
is not the time to flag in our support
for Ukraine
there are results
um from the sanctions the nuclear threat
the sabotage of the pipelines are just
an attempt to intimidate us we need to
provide Ukraine with more arms more
quickly because now is the time if we
want to make the war shorter we need to
stand firm with our support our
determination Ukraine must win it can
win and it will win
for one and a half minutes
Putin's regime has continually violated
international law since the very
beginning of Russia's latest aggression
against Ukraine but actually long before
that remember Crimea the Sham
referendums that took place in four
Ukrainian regions two weeks ago
constitute yet further mockery of
international law and Democratic
principles this so-called referendums
which happen in military occupied
territories with a brutal war of
aggression ongoing and with forced
displacements of population were simply
a protects for the illegal and violent
annexation of Ukrainian territories they
were nothing but another of Putin's felt
attempts to feign legitimacy for a
criminal aggression but make no mistake
this has got nothing to do with the
Democratic right to self-determination
which is a honorable right that has to
be uphold these fake referendums are not
acts of self-determination they are an
act of external determination the Free
Will of the people cannot be expressed
at gunpoint borders should never be
changed by the use of force we shall
continue to stand to stand firmly with
the people of Ukraine imposing more
sanctions on those who Fuel and sustain
the aggression and blatantly disregard
basic principles of democracy and
international law
thank you next is Nicolas Fest for one
and a half minutes
[Applause]
for president
Madam president thank you very much
and we see
demobilization we hear the nuclear
threat Russia's war against Ukraine is
in a new stage now if the EU wants to be
taken seriously it needs to find an
answer
something more than pointless sanctions
which damage the eu's own countries but
not just the Russia Ukraine war is a
threat to us but an act of piracy
against Nordstrom one and two has shown
the vulnerability of Europe strangely
but this doesn't seem to be a topic on
the agenda everyone just accepts this
shrugging their shoulders
I'm just ignoring the fact of this
damage to a pipeline so who did this
well
we have at the U.S Cruisers we have
a U.S flights in the air the U.S
president said that he wanted to stop at
Nord streamer to and
the uh and Anthony blinken
sees the opportunity of the sabotage uh
to sell a gas to Europe and
um we've seen a member of the parliament
putting out tweets about this and who
was the perpetrator many say uh Putin
but it could be North Korea
Iran or Greta tunberg
so
we have made a request as
an amendment asking for a clarification
on this and it's not just a question of
destroying it native at the EU
Mr vashikovsky speaking from
seats 840. yes I thank you madam
president commissioner
we should have listened to Poland who
serve on the line mentioned in the State
of the Union Address
Poland was warning you not only about
the Imperial aggressive plans of Russia
we were born because of that your
instrument to challenge the threats are
inaccurate
strategy Compass European economy a
European fish faces
Etc these are inaccurate to face the
Russian threat our recipe was to seek to
Nato and transatlantic relations
and who is now helping or trying to
defend themselves and US European ecos
UK and Poland the country you are
sanctioning and paralyzing
uh how we look for how you face the
child so far the escalation
cooperation with NATO and U.S is a good
direction how how we will have Ukraine
by concrete times will you release funds
of 3 billion euros out of nine promise
we will force European countries to send
more weapons when you stop penalizing
Poland which is helping you find the
most in political military and
humanitarian way thank you thank you I
give the floor next to Manu Pineda for
two minutes
[Applause]
thank you president President Van Der
Lyon vice president Burrell
what Mr Weber said has forced me to
change the start of my speech I think
the Godfather of it the agreement with
his party in Italy with the um
descendant of fascism and
Mussolini in Italy was something in very
bad taste now this is a time when
there's a threat of
nuclear war which is very real
this
War needs to end the best way forward is
diplomacy it's not enough just to make
statements particularly those who've
sown the seeds of this conflict
Putin
is responsible mainly for this war but
NATO with its eastwards expansion hasn't
helped it seems to be a return to the
Cold War and a bipolar world
to the detriment of
multilateralism and the autonomy of
people
and we see that there is a persecution
of social movements and unions and so on
in the country the EU had an opportunity
for an autonomous foreign policy but
decided to subordinate itself to the
United States it's a very difficult
situation for Europe and it's the
working class which has to Bear the bunt
of the crisis and we are firmly
committed to peace and defending the
working class
the EU needs to rethink what it's doing
even just in its own interests we need
to act in time we
I urge Emma for the role of the osce to
um
come to the Forefront again as a
guarantee of peace and security
uh in Europe we should study Mexico's
proposal to the U.N General Assembly it
proposes peace conversations and
tripartite conversations between you and
India and the Vatican this is the right
way forward to de-escalate me more
diplomacy not more NATO for one minute
foreign
I am the chairperson of a Slovak
political party is a Slovak Patriot me
as I a Euro a member of the European
Parliament wanted to see the real
situation in Ukraine and members of my
party were in Ukraine during the
referenda
if to inform
in an unbiased way about the referenda
probably most of you wouldn't believe me
and Mrs fan from The Lion would have to
blush so I will not use this speaking
time for that purpose on the resolution
I will vote on the resolution according
to the truth which means in a different
way than the majority of MEPS thank you
Antonio tayani
I'll give the floor to Antonio
thank you president
never more than today we need a strong
cohesive United Europe
taking
joint choices to defend the rule of law
to defend Ukraine's Independence and to
prevent totalitarian movements around
the world holding its way over
democracies
that's why we need a credible Europe
as far as this energy points are
concerned too
it's an everyone's interest to have a
cap on gas prices
we can't allow the Russian Federation to
divide us
putting our families and businesses in a
difficult situation so we need to thrush
out
checks on gas prices no matter what's
been happening on the Amsterdam stock
exchange perhaps you allow me to say as
a present at this juncture
well I've
been fighting for 28 years this is my
last speech in this house and I want to
confirm
my commitment to a political Europe with
a stronger Parliament with greater
legislative powers
so that in the years to come
all of us
can continue to be proud citizens of
Europe
I'd like to thank all of you starting
with you madam president
I'd like to thank all my colleagues in
my political group but also the other
political groups
and let's put it into Palms I've always
tried to be objective and may I
apologize for any mistakes I may have
made I always sought to show respect for
all MEPS from whatever political group
they might be thank you once again
I'd also like to thank the officials
including the interpreters for
everything they've done to allow us to
become other tongues thank you all of
you I will continue my work in the
Italian parliament
fighting for a stronger political Europe
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
president
the escalation of Russian
measures
and the spectacular defeats are not
really a surprise for those who've been
watching the Vladimir Putin's policies
very closely
through the fake referendums through the
panic mobilization the threats of
nuclear
weapons Russia is hoping that they can
mobilize the remainder of their power
and
try to win back part of sovereign
Ukrainian territory even the closest
allies are shifting away from Russia and
the rest of the world can see that this
is a criminal country or even a
terrorist state
as Europeans we have lived through
decades where there has been we've been
living under the threat of a nuclear
apocalypse we cannot live through that
again so we have to provide Ukraine with
weapons and Industrial support economic
support there needs to be sanctions put
in place against the criminal regime
and also we have to have monitoring of
Russian activities around the world
our weapons are unity and cooperation
and also work within the NATO alliance
there are a lot of places around Europe
and then you see those in Moscow
Brussels or Washington who need to be
monitored we need to
reach those Russians
these people who are being told you're
in the Army now and at the same time the
shops having less and less Goods on
their shelves
Ukraine uh be strong
good morning everyone
now we'll continue through the list of
speakers
coming now to Hilda weltman's who has
one and a half minutes
Consultants thank you president I
representative konigs
after seven months of warfare the threat
of escalation
a military and nuclear escalation is
greater than ever
and it shows how desperate it
boutonnieres of the prospect of his War
failing he's a threat to the world he'll
use every means available to do
destabilize us
and above all to divide us
are we going to allow that or are we
going to stand as one United European
block as we were at the beginning of the
war
the cold winter
is coming colleagues but it must not uh
allow that Unity
to be destroyed so why is the council
delaying
the cap on gas prices why is it allowing
Hungary to hold up assumptions and why
is the driving force of our economy
still doing its own thing instead of
opting for this European wine decision
European leaders will be coming together
as an informal meeting Council on Friday
whether or not it's informal colleagues
important decisions have to be taken
there
and above all that's what I'm saying
that means a European response to the
energy crisis
we must make full use of our European
power as Alexander that the Virgin prime
minister said we can't
get by with any um solo players now it's
it's time to tackle this crisis
present thank you
and now the vice president of parliament
will have the fourth one minute dear
colleagues there are clear signs that
Putin is in the state of weakness in his
War he also risks to be defeated in
Russian Society by the chaotic and
arbitrary mobilization he dismissed the
social contract with Russian people that
vast majority of Russians who have until
now remained indifferent to Putin's War
now have been politicized many of them
now see that the target of Putin's war
is also Russian people
Against All Odds also the normally
obedient media is criticizing the
failures of Putin
but by threatening Ukraine and the whole
world with nuclear weapons a point has
been reached where calls for regime
chains are more than legitimate
they should not be any more a taboo for
anyone inside nor outside Russia now we
must stand by the side of the Russian
Democratic forces also those who have
had to leave Russia they never gave up
their fight for Democratic future of
Russia even during the ever-growing
repression so now is the time when we
can make a change working together with
these Democratic forces
[Applause]
thank you
the next speaker is Madison for one and
a half minutes Mr President uh
approximately Mr layer has left at this
web commissioner here first of all
because I can agree with most of you
like who have told before in last one
hour that we have to support Ukraine
that Russia is aggressor that's
absolutely true there's no doubt about
that but the main question is that how
we can go forward what are the next
steps what we can do for Ukraine
as much as I know we still import oil
from Russia we still are paying millions
of Euros every day to Russia we're still
continuing this
we are still waiting with a bigger
military help to Ukraine I know exactly
in the fact that there is a deal to give
more more Military Support to Ukraine
but there is just one signature missing
by Mr Schultz from Germany
is only his signature is missing to keep
more Military Support to Ukraine by the
German companies
now it's the question that's okay we can
blame Hungary yes also they are pretty
much wrong sometimes we can blame some
other countries
but in the meantime
we are just waiting for German counselor
to give that one signature to give more
Military Support to Ukraine
and about the blackmailing what Russians
are doing now of course now they are
losing territories every day in Ukraine
and that's amazing we like this but now
they're blackmailing with the nuclear
power and I can see like even in the
western world that how more and more
people are getting really afraid you
know that oh maybe they're really so
crazy that they will start a nuclear war
oh maybe they will relax try to do this
but find the question is okay if they're
really ready to do this it will be the
suicide of Russia because finally in the
end of the day they will lose this war
even in the nuclear war
and we are nuts in this position to say
to Russians that okay let's sit down and
have a diplomacy because Russians
entered diplomacy in the morning of 24
February in this case today we have to
win in this war in every prize thanks so
much
thank you the next speaker is from
Veronica verzio Nova she has one and a
half minutes
thank you very much we have to continue
to provide support to Ukraine to
preserve peace and Security in Europe
the energy crisis is having an effect on
different countries in different ways
but we shouldn't allow ourselves to be
divided by this this obviously Russians
objective and we certainly shouldn't
give up
we shouldn't be afraid of Russian
Putin's threats we have to respect the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine and we
have to help them to fight against
Russian aggression
the threats from the Russian dictator
the falsified referendums
the attempts to integrate Ukrainian
territory in the Russian Federation
these are all
pieces of evidence that Military Support
to Ukraine is working
Putin has noted
that Ukraine Ukraine can liberate its
own territory and so he stepped up his
actions by mobilizing by transferring
other military units closer to the
conflict Zone
Putin cannot win this war
and we can help him lose it so we have
to continue to provide support to
Ukraine and we have to show Unity
thank you the next speaker is Sylvia
modig she has two minutes
thank you president
this Russian aggression
continues against international law we
cannot backpedal
on our efforts to support Ukraine
inquiries have to be made into what
happened regarding the sabotage of the
gas pipelines
we must make sure that all critical
infrastructures are protected from
potential sabotage
Russia
is using this energy crisis to win the
day you will have noted the price Rises
which are purely speculative
it's a weapon that Putin is wielding
against us
at this point we need to take the
necessary steps to ensure that we get
through this winter
and we come out of it intact
the energy economy is ever more
important in this context it seems to me
that the conditions are there for us to
take action we must be United
with our sanctions on Russia but also in
camping gas prices
there were these sham referendums
carried out
decided on behind the Russians but
that's just a smoke screen
when all said and done those areas
are being liberated by the Ukrainian
Army
and will return to Ukrainian rule
we must continue our support to the
ukrainians as I was saying we must give
them fresh hope
that help needs to be financial and
Military too
we also need
to make sure that dissident Russians who
want nothing to do with this war are
able to enter your internity safely
and lastly we have to tackle this
nuclear threat it's a threat to the
whole planet
it's just making conflict even worse so
let's take the necessary steps to remove
that threat
and the president thank you the next
speaker is Martin June Joshi as one
minute thank you Mr President dear
colleagues
the war in the Ukraine has triggered
exemplary European Unity but it has also
shown that Europe is powerless
which is quite remarkable if we consider
the aggregate size of our national
armies the aggregate volume of Our
National Defense budgets and the
abundance of weapon systems and
capacities within the EU
but now it should be clear to all of us
that sanctions are essential to limit
Russian aggression but they are
certainly not sufficient to win a war
the past weeks have shown how dangerous
external dependence on energy can become
it is high time to realize the risks
inherent in the Eternal dependence on
the U.S to guarantee European security
with Trump's four years in office and
the Dreadful Prospect of his return for
a second term should be alarming for all
of us
so my question to you Mr schefter which
is the last representative of the
Commission in this room today what are
the commission's plans and proposals for
the protection of European citizens from
an escalating conflict thank you very
much
thank you the next speaker is uh Rhonda
swansikovski one minute ladies and
gentlemen
Mr Putin all you have achieved with your
bogus annexations is that Ukraine will
no longer negotiate with you
your situation is very precarious
you can no longer win
but you still have some room for
maneuver
a previous ruler of Russia Nicholas II
also attacked what was perceived as a
weaker adversary Japan in 1904 and also
lost both on land and at sea
he uh concluded a peace instituted
internal reforms
and gained himself 12 more years in
power
Mr Putin
you probably won't do it because you're
more of an egomaniac than a patriot and
you'll probably end up in some bunker
Steiner will not come
and you will go down
the choice is yours thank you
[Applause]
thank you the next speaker is Sven mixer
two minutes uh Mr President
makes it
remains Russian strategic failure
by his mobilization his illegal
annexation and his nuclear safe rattling
is desperately trying to raise the
stakes
and so as to scare ukrainians and their
allies
but ukrainians are not going to be
intimidated by Putin's Blaster and
neither should we
ukrainian's courage and resolve in
defending the Homeland has been amazing
throughout the conflict
but the recent success on the
battlefield also owes to the support
they have received and continue to
receive from allies in Europe and
elsewhere
in order to consolidate the recent gains
Ukraine needs much more of our support
sure we all want peace to come to
Ukraine as quickly as possible but to be
durable and sustainable it will have to
be a just peace and in case of this war
this means the full restoration of
Ukraine sovereignty and territorial
integrity
after Putin's sham referendum and
Declaration of annexation of Ukraine's
Sovereign territory
the restoration of Ukraine's territorial
Integrity effectively means driving the
occupiers out by force
the faster this happens the sooner a
just and durable piece returns to
Ukraine
yes Europe has done a lot but now it's
not time for self-congratulation for we
have done much but not enough whether we
compare our performance to that of the
Americans or to our own previous
commitments
we must not hesitate and we must not be
afraid to give Ukraine all the weapons
including tanks that they need to
successfully complete the liberation of
the country
quick and decisive liberation of all
Ukraine's territory is the quickest
path to a lasting peace and these thus
actually de-escalatory
as to those who Aspire a diplomatic
approach
I would say this
yes when the liberation of all of
Ukraine has been made irreversible then
we will indeed have a lot to discuss at
the negotiating table including how to
make sure that all those responsible for
war crimes are brought to Justice
and also the issue of what needs to
become of Russia so that it can never
again Slaughter innocence innocent
people and threaten International Peace
thank you
[Applause]
thank you the next speaker is our vice
president Michael schumachka one minute
thank you very much
commissioner Vladimir Putin is losing
his aggressive and brutal War
and the attacked Ukraine together with
Europe which helps Ukraine military and
financially are winning let us not get
misled or frightened by putting threats
of using nuclear weapons or by his
massive mobilization where we see more
Russians fleeing than joining it or
let's not get frightened by illegal
annexation of territories where Putin is
gradually losing control over it because
this is the only Putin's tactic the only
weapon he has is to spread fear
blackmail everyone Massacre civilians
burn land manipulate Energy prices and
endanger Europe's critical
infrastructure but in reality he is weak
if Ukraine and Europe should win this
war we must stay united we must adopt
harder sanctions and continue delivery
heavy Armory to Ukraine the victory of
Ukraine will be also the victory of free
and Democratic Europe thank you
thank you I'll give the floor now to
promise rope one minute
colleagues
now high ranking you
give this warnings of the Baltic states
about Russian plants fell on deaf ears
but what's the meaning of these words of
these regrets if the situation today
remains almost unchanged
the introduction of new sanctions is
losing Pace atrocious Crimes by Russian
military scores less and less emotions
in the end Europe is only reacting to
the acts of Putin instead of taking
proactive steps in advance of a new
attack
have no doubt
ever since launching the war in Ukraine
in 2014
the Kremlin has been sticking to its
goals
talking to an aggressor is useless
and phone calls appealing to Common
Sense and democracy diplomacy bear no
fruit at all we have to understand that
common sense is non-existent in the
Kremlin
and we have to act correspondingly thank
you
thank you the next speaker is Peter
coffin one and a half minutes
thank you president
when Ukraine
was attacked
everyone thought it wouldn't last long
but that's not what happened the
situation has changed fundamentally
things are not going well for Russia on
the battlefield
the Russians never won uh swiftly the
way the ukrainians are pushing the
Russian for this back show how
ineffective they are and the soldiers
don't seem to be very motivated at all
when's the need to mobilize more
soldiers
many of the concepts um consequently
leaving Russian territory Putin has
underestimated Ukraine
and uh
ignore their action for the West
sanctions are not going to disappear
they will remain and I support them and
I call for far more of them
before the beginning of the war many
leaders
weren't listening to the polls and and
people from the Baltic republics were a
warning of the threats of working with
Putin
there are those in the west still
talking to put it
Russia needs to learn
it must be aware of the consequences of
unmotivated attacks on a peaceful
neighbor
Europe must reduce its dependency on
Russia
and it must also provide some motivation
for the ukrainians
allowing them to push the Russians out
of occupy territory
the West must not seat an inch to Putin
now whatever in the future thank you
foreign
Russia's war against Ukraine has started
in 2014.
and some woke up to it only this year
while we in central eastern Europe were
screaming about the growing danger of
Russia's Imperial appetite others in the
EU were supporting Russia with generous
military and energy contracts
it was a fatal mistake with heavy
repercussions and losses
today many recognize Poland baltics and
other countries Frontline countries were
right and but not listened to
today the same people continue not to
listen and not to follow
informed advice of central East European
countries
the Frontline central European countries
were the only besides U.S and UK
to give immediately a big part of the
effort and budget to support Ukraine's
fight and to receive this time through
refugees
EU did not help adequately frontlined
member states
many in the EU
even now are opposing to send military
equipment
and this verse already promised money
not to mention increase
it is our urgent imperative
and your team to give more heavy weapons
and more Finance
and join the U.S initiative of monthly
1.5 billion transfers to Ukraine budget
to put to zeros and sanction Russia to
enforce payments of reparations to
Ukraine and finally to accept the real
Ukraine in NATO thank you
foreign
thank you very much president vice
president of the commission
representative of the council ladies and
gentlemen
the time for playing with words is over
a conflict in Eastern Europe has now
really entered our homes and is
threatening to attack the quality of
life
uh of people in Europe throughout the
winter and the danger of nuclear Wars
increased as well
and at the moment the Czech government
the European Union and NATO are doing
nothing but adding more fuel to the fire
there's a crazy competition of who is
going to provide more weapons in this
fractional War who's going to show more
courage in fighting to the last
Ukrainian
the recent terrorist attacks on gas
pipelines from Russia to Germany didn't
just damage the interests and property
of these two countries but also
threatened social peace throughout
Europe
and the various approaches of the West
and Washington Berlin vis-a-vis Ukraine
is showing we are divided and maybe you
remember what U.S President Joe Biden
said at the beginning of February when
he threatened to terminate Nordstrom in
the presence of the German Chancellor so
I call on the EU institutions to use
their influence take the initiative
start conducting peace negotiations and
that can is the only way to lead to the
end of this conflict and the sooner the
better internet
thank you Francesco Donato is the next
speaker for one minute
thank you president news from the front
tells us that Ukraine is winning the war
are we sure that Putin will uh agree
with the losses without stepping up the
level the nuclear threat is becoming
even more probable
General Petraeus the former head of the
CIA is taught in terms of triggering a
third world war
but those who come populists in Europe
want peace talks butinski in the
European Union saying no
now what I wonder is this
will the European Union survive this war
I really don't think it will
because we have to ask ourselves when
the bombs are going to start falling on
our cities
are we going to do what Mr Sikorski did
when the the gas line was bombed he said
thank you U.S
shouldn't also be saying thank you to EU
at least that's what our citizens will
say
let's carefully think through how many
human lives and businesses we want to
sacrifice I would ask you please let's
end this madness
thank you the next speaker is Siegfried
morishan one minute
thank you Mr President dear colleagues
the first and most important thing is to
observe and recognize reality on the
ground and reality is that Ukraine is
winning this war Russia is losing this
war and Russia knows it Russia is
answering with aggressiveness and Russia
is answering with propaganda and our
first important duty is to tell the
truth to the people of Europe to make
sure that the people of Europe are
properly informed we have to tell to the
people that Russia is failing militarily
it is failing politically economically
and it is failing morally what do we do
we have to stay united we have to help
each other within them within the
European Union we have to help our
neighboring countries we have to help
Ukraine and we have to continue
sanctioning Russia sanctions work there
are no more investments into Russia
Russia has no more access to our top
Technologies and next year it will have
no more revenues from gas and fossil
fuels from us we saw last week that
Russia is trying to also affect our
immediate neighboring countries it cut
by 30 percent the gas supplies to the
Republic of Moldova a EU candidate
country we have to help there and
commissioner vice president amounts
which are small for us make a big
difference and will help keep the
Republic of Moldova an EU candidate
country on the European path thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you the next speaker is
two minutes
thank you Mr President more than seven
months since the start of its aggression
things are not going as planned for
Russia
what was supposed to be a quick special
military operation turned into a long
battle where Ukrainian forces showed
exceptional bravery and even start to
advance
the pipeline that was a significant
source for financing for Russian
aggression is sabotaged in desperation
Kremlin began to mobilize
I believe that once again this house
will confirm a strong tax resolution and
this lead the way for future actions our
demands and suggestions are precise we
want and ask for another robust package
of sanctions targeting anyone involved
in this illegal referenda as we will
never recognize its so-called results
coordinated actions on the Visa and
Asylum applications of the Russian
citizens and concrete proposals for
advanced Military Support
I would also like to reflect on the
great sense of unity permanently shown
by this house
since the start of the Russian
aggression on Ukraine one of the most
critical tasks is maintaining Unity
among our governments and citizens as
well
we have to be clear and say the origin
of all problems that our citizens are
dealing with high energy prices food
supply problems and security threats are
caused by the actions of the Russian
regime
the firmer we are with our sanctions the
sauna David land and the change in
Russia should come from within therefore
we should increase our support to those
in Russia who raise their voices against
the Putin regime and can be the drivers
of this change this war will end Putin's
regimes Slava Ukraine
um
thank you the next speaker is for one
minute
foreign
ladies and gentlemen the question we
need to put today is to ask ourselves
where we are well on the Ukrainian side
the counter-offensive is being crowned
with a massive success because the
advances to the East are now seeing
where liberating troops are heading
towards Curson
on the Russian side on the country we
can see a political debacle added to the
military tobacco the highest echelons of
the regime are starting to accuse one
another of negligence in the harsh light
of the public eye and this has never
happened before Russia's chain of
command and Putin himself we can see in
no longer untouchable
and it's the start of this General
disintegration we saw with the partial
mobilization first signs of emancipation
of Central Asia the success that our
sanctions are having and the rather
strange and persistent assertion from Mr
pigeon boss of a powerful militia who's
nurturing his own Ambitions the Sun is
setting on an aging czar
but at this time he is more dangerous
but he will still lose
thank you
thank you the next speaker is our
colleague Viola from come on to a hotel
one minute
Mr President
um commissioner colleagues Putin is
neither a master strategist nor a
geopolitical genius he is a terrorist
who is only capable of bombing children
and blackmailing us with doomsday in
these efforts useful idiots are his main
asset these useful idiots and there are
plenty from politicians to Tech
entrepreneurs should not be allowed to
define the narrative
the chaotic mobilization of troops and
threatening the world with nuclear
weapons only prove one thing Putin is
desperate desperate
because he's losing the war that he vote
to win in three days desperate because
his sanctions are biting and his
propaganda cannot outweigh the empty
Russian Riches for long desperate
because he hears the voices of mutiny in
the Kremlin corridors getting louder and
louder Putin is Russia's greatest enemy
and his end is in sight until then we
will continue standing firmly with
Ukraine arm them with heavy weapons
support the EU Initiative for tanks so
that its brave people finally win this
war thank you
thank you
foreign
for one and a half minutes
colleagues in the light of
War International or calls for the
aggressor to be
condemned and the aggressive party to be
defended I therefore
decry
the invasion of Ukraine and the
annexation Marsha of four Ukrainian
regions it's an unacceptable attack on
the territorial sovereignty the
territory Integrity of the sovereign
state this is a fundamental rule of
international law
from Arrested Beyond went to Victoria
you go those who've defended business
scientific Nations have always rejected
the use of Armed Force these
demands have to be directed at Russia
first of all and it's it's president
which who went for under question
against the neighboring country but also
have to be directed to the president of
the European commission who recently
came along to Tellus that only a
military outcome could end this dramatic
conflict which is um tearing European
peoples apart no the European Union
should not give in to um wide
um
Wild
mongering this war can only be brought
to an end by a ceasefire negotiations
the war camp in Brussels must stop this
crazy escalation following
Washington's orders to humanate
Russia
[Music]
to peace rather than being the footstool
for on a nip it into America thank you
thank you the next speaker Nicola
brokerchini one minute
thank you president
this war unfortunately involves us all
indirectly in terms of the military and
economically so we shouldn't commit to
mistakes we shouldn't make our choices
alone particularly when it comes to
energy the gas price cap and the
electricity price cap if they are to
come along in the next few days are too
late for businesses and families in
Italy and in Europe there's a need to
act quickly the second mistake we should
have avoid is division internally the
political campaign against certain
conservative governments is a real
Injustice
hitting those European states which are
bearing the brand of the geopolitical
crisis I'm Italian and
I know which government is in the firing
line but I hope that left's hatred for
democracy will not be greater than
Putin's hatred for democracy but allow
me to be rather pessimistic on that
score
but thank you
the next speaker
is Andrea bochkor one minute
thank you president
224 days of War
that taking the toll among citizens and
children and more than 10 million people
were forced to leave their homes the
feeders group in this Parliament has
condemned and condemns the Russian
aggression
and the annexation of Ukrainian
territories and war crimes committed
since the beginning we have been in
support of the Integrity of the of
Ukraine and we do not accept the results
of the fake referenda
hungry's history's largest humanitarian
aid program is going on and we have
received more than one million refugees
from the Ukraine we are in our interest
is a piece which observes the integrity
and sovereignty of Ukraine only this can
stop the suffering of War only this can
stop this raging of Madness it is
unacceptable on the other hand
to connect
the solidarity of the ukrainians with
the full energy sanctions
against Russia because this divides
Europe and the sanctions the energy
sanctions are contradictory
thank you very much it's now my pleasure
to give the third to vice president what
macaras
is
president commissioner ladies and
gentlemen
resolution unity and solidarity security
and support
those are the orders of the day I had an
opportunity last week to represent the
Parliament and go to Kiev the capital of
Ukraine to carry out discussions my
working visit arrived on the same day
that Putin decided to Annex and announce
further
areas of Ukraine with these unacceptable
injustices and irresponsible worrying
decisions that he's taken
the illegal bogus referendums
the nuclear threat and mobilization in
all this Putin is
stepping more and more close to
escalation he's turning up the pressure
now the persistence and resolution and
resilience of the ukrainians have
surprised me and encouraged me so that's
why I support increasing sanctions and
the package of measures from the
commission and I also support the
measures that the president commission
president of the commission announced to
us today to reorganize the energy Market
to make sure that the price mechanism is
brought in that will help
[Applause]
thank you
the next speaker is our colleague what's
the muse
one and a half minutes
thank you sir
Russia continues its centuries along
tradition of conquering new lands and
other nations it neglects the fact that
it is a brutal breach of international
law
being an economic dwarf feeling that in
the future its main sources of wealth
will lose much of their present
significance it wants to strengthen its
International position with use of force
having little to say in scientific and
technological competition Russian
leaders supported by many Ordinary
People want other nations to feel fear
then there is a personal Obsession of
the leader who would like very much to
rebuild something similar to the Soviet
Union
aggression against Ukraine is a step in
this direction
this is a major violation of law
aggressors are responsible for terrible
number of killed people demolished
cities and Villages bombarded
infrastructure
to hide compromising battle failures
they decided to officially steal part of
Ukraine and threaten the where the rest
of the world to its use of nuclear arms
we all not only Europeans must
understand that this is equal to the
final termination of life on Earth
giving up is not an option it will not
stop Russia the only thing we can and
should do is to support the victim
Ukraine as much as possible and as much
as needed to defeat an aggressor and to
show that we are able to defend life law
and Liberty thank you
[Applause]
thank you the next speaker
representative
thank you very much I think in recent
months we but also representatives of
the citizens and those who lead the EU
institutions have land an important word
courage
we have been standing by the side of
Ukraine in this criminal and unjustified
and unprovoked War started by Putin from
the beginning we've supported Ukraine
we've supported them with wheat exports
we've taken in refugees
it's important that the EU
show this courage
and we've seen results actually the
Russian fronts are crumbling in many
areas
and we've seen the courage of Ukraine
and as well we have to make sure that we
provide support around the world to
maintain Independence and and
territorial Integrity we have to keep up
that those measures freedom and
democracy are important those are parcel
of the values that the union was created
on and it's important that we continue
with that continue to show courage
and as long as we have courage no
dictator will be able to cling to power
not even Putin
thank you the next speaker is yanique
Jadoo for one minute
dear colleagues
of course today we need to step up these
sanctions and all of the assistance to
Ukraine
to obtain Ukraine's military Victory and
the end of
atrocities the high representative
said that what is at stake is a conflict
of values of civilization
but this conflict of this Clash of
civilization and values is really at the
heart of European society as well
and this hasn't affect on European Unity
look at the far right let's
look at their
friendship with Putin the social
injustices at the
which really go to serve their vision
and values look at the increase in
prices as well and the decoupling
between gas and electricity prices is
something which has come too slowly you
need to act more clearly quickly and the
windfall tax as well we're talking about
2.6 billion going to shareholders that's
more than France's budget for heat
renovation if there's no
um social justice
in this um work for the climate in the
fourth
the work we're doing for Ukraine we will
lose when it comes to this Clash of
values
um
yes we can see that the sanctions crazy
idea is being professed once again from
the conservative left majority the
commission of green social Democrats
conservatives they are going to really
run this continent to the wall
look at how people are coping there's
record inflation there's people who are
losing their businesses there's poverty
people don't know how they're going to
get through the winter and the the
advice as well just stop height heating
turn it off just freeze through the
winter
I think this is a ridiculous path to
take that leads to an abyss and we need
to sit this from a humanitarian point of
view we are living through difficult
times and there are voices who are
calling for peace in these times it's
not the evil right that you always
invoke
we hear speeches
where people who are such as the
business people one of the most
successful businessmen in the world Elon
Musk for example and also the pope all
asking us to sit down at the table and
try and stop the killing so that in
Europe we can maintain Prosperity that
we can make it through the winter for
with our heating so that people don't
need to freeze people aren't scared of
losing their jobs and their prosperity
running into the sand and their savings
to be lost to record inflation and this
continent to be dragged down into
further deeper problems I can only once
again appeal to you
to speak with a strong European voice I
am concluding
the warring factions need to be forced
to the negotiating table and find a
common solution that everybody can
accept thank you
[Music]
thank you very much and now Alexander
vondra you have the four
ladies and gentlemen today I will be
positive because we have equality uh
resolution ahead of us which contains
all important elements our reminder that
Russia Bears the full responsibility for
the war
our reiteration of the full support for
Ukraine including our call to increase
the massive military assistance and also
calling to explore the possibility for
landless military assistance something
what I have already proposed during the
last plenary
also we are rightly condemning the
referee and the so-called referenda to
Annex the four Ukrainian regions as
illegal and alleged agreement and last
but not least we are also condemning the
recent Russian threats to use nuclear
weapons as irresponsible and dangerous
and calling
that we would not be deterred by further
in our further assistance to Ukraine and
self-defense that's all good maybe one
thing is missing here and that's to
designate that threatening the use of
force the nuclear force should be
labeled or designed as a threat against
peace and Humanity so let's reckon that
because it's unprecedented rhetoric by
Putin
thank you very much the next one is Mr
lefteros
Nicolo avalovanos you have the floor
is
the annexation of Ukrainian territories
that President Putin announced means
that we have more oil
in the fire of this imperialist war and
of course we have the support to Mr
zelinski with new material so we have
a conflict between eurasianism and the
Asian Bloc with Russia China but within
the Eurozone as well between Germany
France and Italy
so the threats from both sides for the
use of nuclear weapons the sabotas of uh
the pipelines means that the peoples in
Ukraine and the whole world pay a high
price under these conditions degree
Greece must move away from this war and
the NATO plans for war so we need to
stop right now sending material to
Ukraine and we should no longer use
Greek territory for a staging ground for
this war and
so it needs in every country we need to
do everything to stop this work
thank you very much and the next one is
Miss dollar monstera you have the floor
thank you President Putin is continuing
his War escalation calling up reservists
the the illegal referenda Europe needs a
firm response with sanctions on Russia
with no beating about the bush this is a
war criminal we're talking about here
when there's a criminal wall there you
can't uh give way at all
but we also have to tackle in inflation
the impact on prices we need an urgent
reply for families and small firms they
can't make ends meet
in in Spain we used to be one of the
cheapest now we're monastic expensive
countries in Europe
produces our tripling the
Energy prices citizens are already
saving energy not because we're asking
them to do so it's because they can't
actually pay for it in Spain while
families are economically struggling the
government
we'll get it an extra 30 billion
Euro because we've been placed in the
last year that money should be returned
to Citizens pockets
you have to bring down taxes so that
millions of families and firms do not
face Reuben yeah
thank you very much and now Amis Isa you
have the floor
thank you very much president commission
Council
Russia's terrible Wars affecting the
Ukrainian population every single day
and it's threatening peace in Europe and
Security in Europe as well now that
Russia is escalating the war we social
Democrats believe that the commission's
calls for Unity and solidarity are
decisive
and that commissioner Johansson's
guidelines on the Visas are reasonable
in this particular security situation we
think that the leaks that have happened
at nordstream one and two in the Baltic
Sea need to be investigated properly
this presumably
attack of sabotage have happened in
Swedish and danish economic zones so
it's very serious just a few miles from
where I live Putin's cold-blooded
actions in Ukraine and the illegal
annexes have to be stopped we in the EU
have to continue our strong cooperation
because one thing is sure
Putin will not come out of this
Victorious thank you
thank you very much the next one is Mr
ilyang kuchuk you have the floor
colleagues ladies and gentlemen Europe
has done a tremendous job Europe has
done a lot of things including Military
Support financial support but it's not a
time for a sales celebration we must
continue our support to Brave ukrainians
who are fighting not only for their
designation for their identity and
belonging but they are fighting for for
us for Europeans for European values and
they deserve our admiration and great
support under the leadership of
President zelensky and certainly the
brave ukrainians secondly we have to
resist
and every time Europe is tested tested
by Foreign actors by by big Powers by
Invaders this time I think there is a
greater test of our Unity we have to
resist and put together the European
Union because only if we are able to
come together we will be able to
overcome the crisis and indeed there are
many starting from energy and ending by
social uh consequences of the Christ but
one thing is clear Unity is the key
Unity within the council but also Unity
within the European institutions so
let's unite Europe as never before
[Applause]
foreign
you have the floor
thank you very much president
Putin maintains that the population in
Donetsk luhansk Curson and zaparitia
have freely chosen in the so-called
referendums
but they are against international law
it is a lie
just as the annex of the Crimea
back in 2014 at the start of this war
Russia's Annex sitting
territories in Ukraine are a crime
against international law the list of
war crimes that Putin's been accused of
is becoming longer and longer the
attacks on
Ukrainian populations are hardly even
mentioned on front pages of newspapers
anymore we cannot allow this war to
disappear into the background
the energy crisis is something that will
affect Europe this winter but it's not
the worst thing war is the worst thing
our brothers and sisters in Ukraine are
paying the ultimate price every day and
every day Europe doesn't take those
steps and and stop
buying fossil fuels from Russia we have
to stop
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr dominicainsky you have the floor
thank you Mr President
we should have listened to Poland Ursula
vandelay and said during her Union uh
State of the Union speech
she says we should listen to Poland we
should have listened to Poland but he
didn't want to listen you didn't want to
listen about no stream you didn't want
to listen about illegal migration you
didn't want to listen about Putin and
you didn't want to listen about
sanctions
sanctions what about Russian diamonds
why there is no embargo on Russian
diamonds why
because the capital of the diamonds
industry adverb in Belgium would be
unhappy isn't it
why there is no sanctions on the Russian
diamonds Nordstrom is destroyed but the
diamonds are making money for Russia
so stop lecturing Poland stop pointing
us with your finger stop lecturing us
about democracy do not be a Hypocrites
take actions not a beautiful words be
like Poland be brave believe in your own
Nations instead of being depend on
Russian rubles be brave be like Poland
thank you
foreign
ladies and gentlemen citizens
we need to look at this political
relationships between the super forces
superpowers of Russia and Sid has to be
analyzed objectively if we did that we
could have prevented the war if Mexico
had decided to support the Russian
Federation and place nuclear missiles on
the border with United States what would
be the reaction of the United States
sanctions
we had 70 years of historical experience
how sanctions
influence the attempt to depose
democratically elected leaders
70 years after introducing the economic
sanctions to Cuba and to the North Korea
so today seven decades later
the same dynasties are still in power
did we not learn anything we have to
turn to diplomacy war will only lead to
nuclear war and it will lead to the
death of hundreds of millions of people
we have to use our historic experiences
and turn to peace
oh thank you very much and now the next
one is Andrei kovacho you have the floor
thank you
Ukraine is fighting valiantly since the
start of the war back in 2014 regardless
of their ethnic origin Ukrainian
citizens of valiantly fighting for their
country and all Kremlin expectations for
a blitz Victory are failing and Ukraine
counter of pensive for sporting into
some senseless steps under
mining International and moral Norms
annexing illegally territories of a
neighbor of a neighboring country which
has Independence and whose borders are
un recognized so there is a
a threat of a nuclear action which is
further
blackmail the EU member states have to
continue them as if military Financial
intelligence economic infrastructure
medical humanitarian support for Ukraine
it is
important that Ukraine's desire to join
NATO has to be respected but it is
shameful that the former Bulgarian
government did not support the sending
of military equipment to Ukraine and
colleagues from the left you did not let
this happen it is lamentable that
Bulgarian did not join the Central and
Eastern European countries on Ukraine
thank you
thank you very much and now you are
those Holocaust you have the floor
thank you
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
it's Obama is
foreign
so the only way to solve
this conflict to liberate the occupied
territories of Ukraine is to continue to
provide even more weapons to Ukraine
lastly Putin lately Putin just like an
angry and Raging Bull has been
brandishing the nuclear threat the West
has to be unequipped unequivocal in
stating that should this happen Russia
would erode and eradicate all the taboos
set since the Cold War and all the
Russian targets both in the occupied
Ukraine at in the territory of Russia
including Putin's underground Bankers
would actually become the target of a
retaliers state let's stay United and
let's show our solidarity islava Ukraine
I was I was told that the interpretation
has not been working for parts of the
time is it has it worked
to what they had no
you should probably check this
is
and we're going to be sure to fix the
interpretation
in fact is what we witness In This Very
Room we were never as United as during
this debate and this Unity from one
debate to another is more and more
visible even Alexander vondra was
positive this time
there are of course some shameful
exceptions but they are not even worth
mentioning them
the determination of our leaders to
support Ukraine is also more clear from
day to day week to week month to month
than what we heard from Roberta metzola
Joseph Burrell Ursula Van Der lion is
one voice or the voices that complete
each other member States citizens we all
must follow
it is not even those words it is not
only words because they became facts
actions or very clear plans for the
future and of such a European Union I am
really proud
only so by strengthening our policies we
strengthen also our sovereignty not only
we need to be Sovereign but also Ukraine
needs a strong United Sovereign ready to
pay the price because we know that
otherwise the price will be much higher
thank you
thank you very much and now Pierre
Nicola pedicine the floor is yours
president
thank you peasant commissioner I think
that this time
people are really very fearful
they're afraid because they can see this
escalation is not wanted by just one
side but both
so they're not just afraid of Putin and
his threats they're also afraid of us
westerners let me read you a statement
by Biden released in February before the
Russian invasion if Russia invades
Ukraine
we will
start in Australian make sure it no
longer exists
well the
those declarations are scaring
because we can't see where they want to
get with this
you can't really see either what the
European Union really wants to do given
that no head or social government has
really made any step towards peace
the European Union I think should be
playing the role of a third party to end
this war in everyone's interest the only
head of state who's been brave enough to
say something in this direction is the
Pope
Putin must stop the war and jelensky
should be open to Serious peace
proposals so I would urge you let's at
least listen to what the pope has to say
thank you very much the next speaker is
the floor is yours thank you for thank
you president
colleagues
the EU and NATO is contributing to an
escalation and spiral of the event
sabotage of Pipelines
the use of energy as a weapon against
ourselves illegal annexing of territory
and now threats of nuclear war
Putin has been carried at a hybrid War
for a long time we're only starting to
wake up to that and that lies are
raining there
that he is not shy of breaking
international law and he is targeting
civil infrastructure in his military
attacks
and the EU has to go beyond itself now
make it clear to Putin that we will
never give in to his blackmail
we know that this crisis is going to
affect our energy affect our energy
provision so we have to ensure that we
maintain our critical entities and we
deal with security supply of energy we
need to make sure that the war crimes
are brought to Justice
we should not allow him to move to
nuclear war we have to be Resolute in
reacting against him we shouldn't be
working against his people but against
his regime
and rather than War we should have a
multilateral rule-based order that is
brought back in thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr Paulo Rangel the floor is yours
thank you
Putin's Excursion of the wall mobilizing
reservist with illegal annexations and
nuclear threats forces the European
Union to be more united than ever and
support Ukraine
systematically
that's why we need to ask ourselves this
the s d the greens and the Liberals need
to tell us what their position is
on the unilateral action of the Schultz
government the Socialist liberal green
government in Germany
granting 200 billion euros
without any coordination
without linking up with the work of the
European Union and their partners
subsidizing energy and thereby
destroying confidence amongst them of
states and fragmenting the single Market
yes I want to ask irate Sanchez
from the group on Salt's decision to
take action alone giving 200 billion
euros of subsidies against all the
coordination with our partners thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you to to
limit yourself to the allotted speaking
time because we are running a bit late
and there's a vote at 12 o'clock thank
you very much
the next speaker is
here
Europe is a common and sharing common
understanding and it's very clear we
stand with Ukraine to help it defend its
territory each quadrant meter and to
stay a sovereign state
we need to make the world to see that
any threat to Russians is from their own
president
it's not from NATO EU Europe it's the
president who will threat their morality
economical stunt and sending men to
Ukraine to kill ukrainians
but in this war have in our continent we
also need to protect the rest of the
Europe security is the highest priority
whether it's energy crisis or is it uh
unbearable prices lack of energy because
of so much reducing energy from Russia
it's cold winter to manage if we don't
succeed with the savings too I welcome
the word from the commission president
to raise the protection of the older
critical infrastructure and also I
welcome the words on General guidelines
for Visa issue statement commissioned to
that every member states should take
into account the security when issuing
Vice us to Russians thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Elsie katanan the floor is yours
minister
thank you very much president
commissioner minister
sabotage on the pipeline illegal
referendums and annexations in Europe
repeated mass murders threats of nuclear
weapons we know who are Behind These
atrocities and apart from us pointing
fingers at each other we need to resolve
this crisis in Europe and the quicker we
do that the greater the number of
winners will be
this crisis has to show us that we can't
be dependent on dictators anymore
European autarky is extremely important
we need to have a green transition but
that can't be the only truth we also
have to
make sure that we have energy security
and that means we need to have a broad
range of the energy mix bio energy is
something that shouldn't be restricted
for example
the worse Russia
Stoops the more united we need to be
whether that be on energy use or VISA
policies
we have to make sure we're not split
yeah
the next speaker is Mr cuff
cold winter lies ahead for Putin and his
cronies
and Russia's attempts this week to
illegally Annex four regions in Ukraine
have been rightfully condemned this is
an age of hybrid Warfare and the north
stream attacks reminds us that we are
vulnerable
I'm encouraged by the plan presented by
the commission uh the president this
morning to protect our critical
infrastructure
but I am concerned about the security of
our infrastructure our underground
cables particularly off the coast of my
own country Ireland these cables are
crucial to the functioning of Europe's
Digital Services and a recent report
found that the Irish Defense Forces
cannot adequately protect them so we
need to urgently invest in our defense
capacity on cyber security and on
defending our crucial infrastructure at
this perilous time thank you
thank you very much and the next speaker
is Andres kobilius the floor is yours
dear colleagues
first of all of course congratulations
to Victoria's ukrainians it is clear
that the end of the war depends only on
how much weapons the West delivers to
Ukraine in some way it's shame for you
that United States delivered 25 billion
euros value of weapons and the whole
European Union's support together with
all the member states is only less than
6 billion euros the same is with
financial aid European Union is heavily
behind United States assistance it's not
enough of our solidarity statements real
EU money are needed sanctions are
working but the most painful next
sanction on Putin would be immediate
creation of special tribunal on crime
fagration which would Target directly
Putin Ukrainian military performances
above all the NATO standards not Ukraine
should ask for NATO membership but NATO
should ask Ukraine to join because
Ukraine is supplementing NATO mission to
stop Russia Imperial expanse to the West
we can help Russians to bury their
Imperial dreams we see media Ukraine
NATO membership and negotiations on your
membership started early next year we
shall show to Russia that Ukraine is
gone from Imperial Gray Zone
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you president
more than seven months have gone by
since the Russian army on Vladimir
Putin's orders began its invasion of
Ukraine
and now in the face of the facts as its
plans have collapsed the Russian regime
is acting in an Ever more random
criminal way
illegal annexations with with Shamrock
friends
well
what we need to do is get all the main
players around the world around the
table to work for a fair piece
we're about to have the first meeting of
the European political Community
together with NATO we need a stable
project form as a secure Europe and
independent Ukraine let's move in that
direction
a strong free voice if you could be
crucial in avoiding escalation with
Russia and the US returning to kind of
polarization we had in the Cold War we
don't need that again what we need is
carriage and ambition the world has
changed and the European Union had to
change to to work for a lasting peace
thank you um
thank you very much the next one is Mr
Christensen please the floor is yours
ready for man
foreign
I believe that National States
themselves should choose where they
belong this is why it's unacceptable
when we see the Russian annexation
and their attack from February 24th
we have now also witnessed sabotage
close to Denmark and Sweden in the
Baltic
during the war we see war crimes which
should not happen in 2022.
the Russian aggression has also stopped
the export of
foodstuffs from the from Ukraine and
this has had big consequences for third
countries there's also
as a result of the war an important
energy crisis prices are rising
and this is very costly for European
households and companies the salon and
cold winter ahead of us we need to act
now when Putin forces us to turn down
the heat we need to
improve our production of coal gas and
Shale gas this is how we protect Europe
thank you very much for and the next one
in so
foreign
thank you very much
here vice president of
inter
colleagues
Russian partial mobilization nuclear
threats
the unfair annexation of occupied areas
Putin is increasingly aggressive in his
war on aggression
the Ukraine is defending itself bravely
fighting on its own behalf but also
fighting for our interests and it needs
our full support and I welcome this
eighth sanctions package that you're
working on
but the war also affects us here in the
EU and we must do everything we can in
order to tackle the spiking Energy
prices households can no longer pay
their bills
we have
high gas prices which are driving our
private sector to bankruptcy I welcome
the initiatives of the energy ministers
I think that's a good first step but
they need to be implemented quickly and
effectively and additional measures must
follow we need to have a gas price cap
without endangering
access now this won't solve everything
but it will give us a bit of breathing
space in order to tackle the challenges
we Face we need to work together on both
gas and LNG and we need to work on the
index system for electricity prices as
well as we see all of this is needed
given the current circumstances thank
you well thank you very much and the
next one is yours
thank you president
he had collected colleagues
last weeks have been important it seems
that the war might
reach its end phase and the downfall of
Putin is only a matter of time the
question is when will it happen and how
much harm will the regime be able to do
our support to Ukraine is more important
than ever
together in solidarity and forcefully
even if it means economic difficulties
to our people these are not comparable
to the wall
for the hesitant I suggest to go to
Ukraine and talk to the people there we
mustn't tire and we mustn't give in to
people who talk about peace at every
price
the peace can be achieved only at the
conditions of Ukraine as put a in place
by President zelensky he mentioned five
conditions
um
including
bringing
the perpetrators to Justice thank you
thank you very much the next one is Mr
neostravalsa for resource
the
the president Commission
minister
we actually know how the Russian war
against Ukraine will end
it will end in a total moral societal
economical collapse of Russia
and we already see the first sign of it
but this road to collapse
is long and it's lined with Untold
sufferings
and human death
along this Via Dolorosa marches the
Ukrainian Army
and peoples of Ukraine
in comparison with them we have a fairly
easy walk
but we already complain
sometimes in an unduly manner
now it's time for us to make some small
sacrifices
but making these small sacrifices we
should also be able to open up a
perspective for a Europe in the future
47 years ago the conference of security
and cooperation opened in Helsinki
the principles of the Final Act
have then been torn into pieces by
Vladimir Putin and Russia
we knew need a new conference
we need to get Europe On A New Path away
from the Mortal path Russia under Putin
has chosen thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much the next one is
Madame Sandra Canada
Mr President commissioner
Putin's router
Putin threatens the use of nuclear
weapons NATO warns Putin of severe
consequences ukrainians prepare for
nuclear attack these headlines reflect
the escalation caused by the Kremlin
Putin wants to intimidate anybody who
stands with Ukraine it is just fight
this cannot happen Europe cannot again
succumb to the illusion that Putin can
be engaged in talks and then then he
perhaps might remove the gas supply and
prevent the winter freeze just that way
around the you should increase weapon
Supply to Ukraine so that every next
Victory would trigger more and more
domestic protests because Russia does
not love losers we have to focus more
economic pressure by defining the price
ceiling for oil and gas and by blocking
the exportive nuclear fuel our inability
to agree on sanctions is shameful and
shows that the Putin's escalation is
working Beyond Comprehension is the fact
that so far Ukraine has only received
one of the promised 9 billion Eur Rose
hopefully the 5 billion agreed on
recently will reach Kiev in record speed
slavocray
thank you very much
the next one to speak is Mr Javier
Moreno Sanchez the floor is yours
thank you very much sir
putting is losing the war
in moral and political terms
the Ukrainian the the
the very
brave
Russian young people are saying no to
him and leaving the country the
International Community saying no to him
the only thing he's got left
is blackmail psychological blackmail
faced with which obviously we have to
show solidarity and unity this means
obviously that the cost to be paid by
European citizens
we have an energy crisis a looming and
food insecurity but what we must do is
to make sure that we buy gas
collectively and that we have a strategy
for this
green energy and food security is what
we need and look at what happened at the
WTO last week
and I would tell Mrs monteverette that
taxes are good precisely in order to pay
for the public services that your party
would like to privatize I may remind you
that the forest fires this winter were
not paid for by private thank you very
much
at this level next one is Mr Burger
the president the commissioner the
minister and thank you dear colleagues
for the past 10 years Russia has
invested significantly in its capability
for deep sea water research or the
sabotage capability as we know it for
the past three years Russia deliberately
disconnected itself from the internet
twice without severe consequences for
its own economy or Society
in the end of this year internet cables
were caught in Norway svalbars where EU
Galileo's ground stations are present
and all this time this house asked for
Action Swift action last week two not
three four times North stream one and
not stream two were sabotaged and this
morning only President wonderlion
announced a new plan a new plan against
to protect our critical infrastructure
below sea she announced satellite
civilians stress test and more
cooperation well dear colleagues that's
not even close
not even close to what is needed
this house has the ideas what is needed
we will put them forward in the next
couple of months and we hope to
cooperate with you dear commissioner
boost the maritime safety agency in
Lisbon connect European coast guards
navies make it into a new parability
venue play sensors in our water use
industry data create Pesco projects to
technically update our submarines for
this tasks and last but not least
attribute make sure that every incident
is reported investigated towards the
culprit together with NATO and
neighboring countries thank you slavo
crani
[Applause]
dear colleagues dear guests uh it was
great to see such a strong sense of
unity Unity here of all except of very
very few I guess it's clear what should
be our reaction to escalation of the
situation and increase of the risks
first this is political support at least
as strong as was shown today this
morning the second economic support I
mean economic sanctions and as well
obviously the financial support of
Ukraine we also shouldn't forget on a
humanitarian part of the problem there
are millions of people in Ukraine that
have that have lost home and they can
suffer in Winter and they count on all
support I also very much appreciate
statements of the commission on the on
the energy very good proposals from the
commission can help us to avoid a huge
economic risks this Venture and and
later this is very important and also
keep the social stability that is needed
for continuation of current right course
of our policy thank you very much
thank you very much the next one to
speak is
the floor is yours
thank you
thank you chair
colleagues
Ukraine is a free and independent nation
it is a democracy
and it is Putin and Putin alone who with
his illegal aggression against Ukraine
has brought War back to the European
continent and the answer to this
colleagues I think we all agree must be
Unity cooperation and solidarity and
we've shown that
first with the broad-based support to
Ukraine but also with a succession of
sanctions packages we need to ensure
that we close the tap when it comes to
funding Putin's War
and it's for these reasons that I do
support adding diamonds to the sanctions
packages and I'm saying this is somebody
from Antwerp
cooperation and solidarity are also
needed to tackle the energy crisis and
it would appear that we there's a bit of
a lack of that today
we talk about solidarity
we see that from the council we also
need it from the commission commissioner
I've heard some very good things about
President fondalayan this morning it
really is time to convert that into
action let's set a price cap let's
uncouple this electricity from gas
prices and that will ensure that true
support to European people
that the European people will continue
to support Ukraine thank you
thank you very much the next one to
speak is
Mr President
thank you president commissioner
minister in the European Parliament
which is the heart of European democracy
we can once again confirm our stinting
support to ukrainians we condemn this
escalation as we have condemned all of
that Vladimir Putin's actions bringing
War back to Europe organizing sham
referendums and
ukrainians are not only fighting for
their own freedom but for democracy
itself European democracy
following all these months a ukrainians
nonetheless determined we need to step
up to the plate and show the same
courage as the people of Ukraine we
should not listen to the propaganda the
eighth sanctions package is vital as a
lever to hit the Russian economy
the people of Ukraine are thirsty for
Freedom they have expectations and we
need to continue working hand in hand
with other democracies in order to
consolidate our own strategy and our own
support including supplies and for that
we need to be United and strong Olympic
well thank you very much the next one to
speak is Mr Carlos the floor is yours
foreign
what do we have before us we have a
threat of nuclear war
and the Russians are now using energy
actually
as a weapon
they have weaponized energy against
Europe
what have we been hearing around
from Mr kuchich unlike that we wouldn't
like what he said history has shown that
if we do not stand United if we give in
to tyranny and imperialism in the end we
will get nothing at all history has
shown that we cannot be just take
aggression as and in an ordinary fashion
obviously not we must look at the fact
that this is a country Ukraine that
already 30 years ago had suffered a very
similar aggression what will happen
later after the creating war is
something that's going to Fashion in new
Europe this is the reason why must give
our total support to Ukrainian people we
must make sure that we go back to the
fundamental policies of the European
Union as regards to defense as regards
energy
this is a matter of survival
in this thank you very much the next one
to speak is Mr did Marcus the the floor
is yours go ahead
this war of Russia which runs counter to
international law must end as quickly as
possible recent measures taken by the
Russian regime the illegal referendums
the renewed annexation and the threat of
the use of nuclear weapons must be fully
rejected
nuclear war would lead to complete
destruction on all sides it must be
avoided at all costs
so we need the diplomats to finally take
action and this is the view of 77
percent of all Germans
political offers need to be made in
order to
encourage both sides to lay down their
weapons unfortunately the commission has
been completely inactive in this area
instead there's encouragement to use
more weapons and to stand on the
battlefield and that is not the way
forward yes we need to support Ukraine
economically politically and militarily
but we also need to ensure diplomatic
efforts and too little being done on
that side
we see the Russian people are against
the war and that needs to be supported
as well
Russia is breaking international law and
we in Europe need to do as much as
possible in order to help our partners
thank you
thank you very much the next one to
speak is Madame Francis Fitzgerald one
minute the floor is yours
colleagues the war has entered a
critical use stage with new victories
from our brave and fighting ukrainians
every day Ukrainian forces are advancing
and regaining strategically important
cities yet as Ukraine Advance Putin UPS
his brinkmanship the annexation by
Russia four Ukrainian regions last week
further signified a deepening of his War
efforts his ruthlessness is exemplified
by harrowing images of ukrainians forced
to vote at gunpoint and of course the
shocking images of recently released
prisoners of War
so too the explosion within the
Nordstrom 2 Pipeline and the threat of
the use of nuclear weapons we too in
Ireland must defend our crucial
infrastructure off the coast the threat
draws closer democracy can Prevail in
Ukraine but only with United support and
I mean United right across Europe on all
fronts absolute support on sanctions
ukrainians are fighting for our values
our democracies they fight for us thank
you
chocolate
thank you very much the next one to
speak is Mr Francisco Jose Mian Mona the
floor is yours
thank you Sam
faced with this new escalation there's
one thing that I'd like to stress here
and that is how important it is for the
European Union to
give out a clear message
remember that 141 countries that general
assembly of the United Nations condemned
Russia in March but this condemnation
has been translated into facts there are
very few countries that are actually
applying sanctions and I'm very worried
about the obsession of Brazil and Gabon
in the recent social security
um
Security Council uh vote the president
of the African Union
recently in Moscow said that the
European sanctions ought to be
lifted Putin was in Samarkand recently
with the leaders of India and China
putting is not totally isolated yet and
therefore we must intensify
a diplomatic offensive and the president
of the European Council should get a
more involved in this this is no time
for ambiguity
for indifference this is a conflict
between Russia and the whole of
international capability this is not an
intra-european War it's much faster and
why in that its impact on the rest of
the world is such that the world should
become aware of this and act therefore
in keeping thank you very much the next
one to speak is Mr Trion basescom the
floresios
chair commissioner
Europe is going through a major security
crisis as well as a major energy crisis
how come how come we're here well
because in exchange for gas for oil and
for coal from Russia we've accepted the
situation in transnistria the massacre
in grossney
the annexation of osetia anaphazia in
Georgia and the annexation of Crimea
we just stuck to sanctions that had no
effect on Russia moreover in 2008
a European State blocked the axis of the
of Ukraine to Nato
and now Putin is threatening Ukraine and
Europe that he would use nuclear weapons
and his reasoning is that the United
States have also used nuclear weapons in
1945. indeed
in 1945 the second world war ended
whereas using the nuclear weapons now in
Ukraine would mean the beginning of a
nuclear war
Ukraine needs support in in terms of
weapons in order to defend its territory
and only then can we begin negotiating
thank you
thank you very much the next one to
speak is Mr Vladimir bilchik the floor
is yours
Mr Speaker Mr
commissioner colleagues the
unprecedented attack aggression war
crimes nuclear threats mobilization
referenda annexation the words about
escalation in practice all these words
mean the same Russia keeps crossing the
red line they are destroying Ukraine
threatening European security and they
keep stamping on a European uh and
Global Order the European response must
be unified we need to be unified and
determined we need to join our forces
with our allies in a world we need to
support Ukraine even more than we are
and we need to show that we are not to
be black Pain by Moscow Moscow is on a
path of no return they have abandoned a
civilized society now they are the
outcasts of Global Order every
investment into the victory of Ukraine
is an investment into our own freedom
and security it is investment in our own
democracy in a better future where
Europe will be joined by Ukraine and
once it will join our political sphere
let us stand by Ukraine let us Define
tandem helped them defend their
territories their people their values
ukrainians know how to win this war let
us listen to them and let us give them
what they need Slava Ukraine
thank you very much as the blue card
will not be issued because we're running
out of time and we need to start voting
soon
the next one to speak is
the floor is yours
thank you president
ladies and gentlemen
the EU institutions have firmly
condemned Russia's illegal annexation of
the territory of a sovereign state
we reaffirmed our common determination
to support the freedom and preserve the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine
as well as its economic and energy
Integrity Russia's military invasion of
a neighboring country occupation and
attempt to forcefully seize and
illegally appropriate foreign territory
of the most flagrant examples of
violations of the legal system on which
the European and World Order is based
my country uh Croatia
strongly condemns the violent and
illegal actions we are seeing Energy
prices going up we're all suffering the
consequences of that in Europe but we
must not abandon Ukraine we were the
victims of aggression in Croatia too we
had a struggle for our own freedom and
made major sacrifices we cannot abandon
Ukraine we are speaking the language of
peace they speak the language of War we
must persist in our policies and our
values but we must also be very aware of
Russia's
geopolitical strategy
and we must continue with our measure
I'll Lobby only be to be able to uh to
have three uh catch the eye speeches but
one for each of the groups which have uh
which have applied for it and first Mr
Elgin tomak for 30 seconds
thank you
thank you thank you thank you Mr
President it's clear that Putin has
compromised himself forever and is now
trying to compromise all relationships
that we we could have with Russia um
after
um the moment of Peace we need to stay
the course to remain United
regarding Ukraine because Putin hasn't
managed to reach its goal to Annex
Ukraine within a matter of weeks because
we showed unity and right now the
Ukrainian Army is ever more determined
more organized because they feel that
we've got their back and Putin uh is in
disarray and keeps threatening with the
nuclear weapon
it's high time for this Tyrant to
understand that he cannot keep going
um further with this policy of Terror
and blackmail we need to show solidarity
and unity against this Tyrant thank you
very much
thank you very much thank you very much
the next one to speak is
thank you chair commissioner
I'd like to ask a question about the
president of the commission's
Declaration of course the energy crisis
and the conflict in Ukraine uh are
things that
um make each other worse so we've
discussed about capping the gas price I
create I guess everyone agrees but what
does the president mean by mentioning a
homogeneous level what does that mean
there are countries where consumption
per capita is four times less than the
European average and this is the case of
my country
those who already consume less can they
all cut down even more I think we should
pay attention here and the commission
should suggest a mechanism that would
not be
um detrimental to Citizens that already
use less such as the citizens of my
country thank you
thank you very much and last one to
speak is Mr Giorgio skirtsos the floor
is yours
thank you very much sir
the war Unleashed by Russia upon Ukraine
has entered into a new phase which means
new obligations for us Ukraine is
showing that it is very effective and
it's very generous and therefore we must
increase the Strategic assistance given
to that country by the European Union
because they're far too dependent on the
United States military assistance and
they this may have an influence on their
future decisions
we must win the war of information ideas
against the putting we're doing so
because putting is now undergoing
internal pressure but we must step up
our efforts and we cannot succumb to any
form of populism
last there's still big European
interests that are
actually making a profit out of this war
of put-ins and therefore we must set
even more limitations we cannot simply
allow that the sacrifice of so many
should enrich a few
thank you very much
the next one to speak on behalf of the
European commission will be its vice
president
take your seats quietly
so that we can hear Mr Mr sheikhovich's
presentation thank you
thank you very much Mr President uh Mr
President of the Council of the European
Union Minister back
today's debate uh focus on the most
important challenges of today's Europe
you all mentioned war on our continent
rightly pointed out the serious concerns
of the people in Europe on
High inflation High Energy prices
overall social cohesion and of course on
the future of our businesses and
Industry and I really would like to
thank all the honorable members for what
I felt was truly overwhelming support
and solidarity with Ukrainian people and
I think that we can also say that every
day we see that our support is crucial
that it works and it brings tangible
results
an ocean referenda are going to change
that
and I agree with Mr
austravichus or with Mr myanmong that
the decisions we are taking today will
frame the European and I would say
Global Security for many decades
almost all of you honorable members are
highlighted how important the unity and
solidarity are to deal with current
Energy prices
and high inflation as madam what month
has said this is time for truly European
Solutions because only that approach
will bring results we need and you know
that together with your support we
already did a lot we reduced gas
consumption we decreased gas supplies
coming from Russia in a significant
Manner and we filled up our storages
but we all know that more is needed and
therefore we are going to scheme
exceptional profits of the energy
companies to support vulnerable citizens
and businesses and thanks to the
excellent work of the czech's presidency
we already found an agreement on repower
you to provide additional resources in
those efforts
it's clear that the next days will be of
crucial importance for pushing our
actions to the next level
president Wonderland will send roadmap
in a letter
to prepare the ground for meeting of EU
leaders in Prague
we will complement it with our
negotiations with the trusted Partners
as for example Norway to dump and price
we pay for energy and we are going to
use much more our strong Market power as
being big economy and very important
energy importer
I am sure that our suppliers especially
our friends and allies want not only to
conclude the deals which are beneficial
for both sides but they also want to
support us in our principal positions to
help you crying and further increase
pressure on Russian aggressors
we want to make sure that we will take
advantage of our big internal markets
and we will strengthen our energy
platform to avoid situation where member
states aren't are competing with each
other but rather we would work with them
to support common approach
to take on inflationary impact of gas on
electricity today the president of the
commission was very clear in sending
clear signals on our Readiness to
discuss cap on price
for gas for generating electricity
we see it as another step not only to
develop the new
post ttf price Benchmark but also to
structurally reform our electricity
Market as it was called for by Messiah
or Madam fan Brent and to do it in a way
that will not only decouple gas from its
unproportional impact on electricity
price but to forge new framework which
will correspond to our goals to be
climate neutral continent by 2050. on
top of it as you know we are working on
adaptation of temporary state aid
framework to current energy situation
and I want uh to reassure you that we
hear very loud and clear your calls to
look for additional ways how to tackle
High inflation reduce energy prices and
preserve our competitive competitiveness
and most importantly for our citizens to
uphold social standards in Europe
there have been concrete questions by Mr
murshan on Moldova just to be very brief
on top of our budgetary support and our
macro financial assistance in more than
uh 225 million uh together we are also
helping through eib and we are helping
with sending out the frontex officers to
deal with immigratory flows
I want also to acknowledge very clear
questions in point by Madame friedson
and Madame kumpula natri concerning the
visas
for Russians and here I think the very
concrete guidelines proposed by my
colleague ilwa
johanssons are I think the best way
forward
to Mr Bart group is I want to reassure
him that we are ready to explore all
possibilities
to look for additional Avenues how to
better protect our critical
infrastructure and we'll be looking
forward to our cooperation in that
regards so to conclude honorary members
I really would like to thank you for
today's debate for bringing lots of new
ideas to the table and to really make
sure that as we always do we will
prevail also this crisis and we will
emerge stronger from this very
challenging experience thank you very
much Mr President
thank you very much and on behalf of the
council we will now listen to the Czech
Minister for European Affairs Mr
mikolajbeck the floor is yours Mr
President honorable members commissioner
by the way I appreciate the opportunity
to speak to a full house for a change
the views
the views expressed here today by
witness to this parliaments of a helmink
and continued support for the eu's
course of action towards Russia's war of
aggression against Ukraine
listening to I reiterate the words
expressed by the high representative our
efforts must continue our strategy to
come to Russia's offensive has worked
until now and must be sustained support
Ukraine in all terms pressure Russia and
engage with the rest of the world
we will continue to provide military
assistance to the Ukrainian government
to ensure that recent military gains are
sustainable in the long run we also need
to continue supporting Ukraine
financially in a predictable way
in working with our International
Partners we will make sure that Russia
is held accountable for the crimes it
has committed and we will develop
stronger tools to counter Russia's
parallel wall of this information
High representative Burrell spoke at the
beginning about the eighth sanctions
package and here I am pleased to inform
you that EU ambassadors correct
confirmed agreement on this package
couple of minutes ago
we
[Applause]
we see this package as a further step to
isolate the Russian regime and weaken
its capacity to pursue this war of
aggression the new sanctions package
also represents a strong condemnation of
the recent Shem referenda and of
Russia's illegal annexation of Ukrainian
territories
president vice president of the
commission honorable members as you know
the motto of our presidency is Europe as
a task inspired by an essay by Czech
what president barzoval it is
symbolically today the day of Arts
birthday that we are discussing one of
the most important tasks that lie ahead
of us many thanks for your attention
thank you
foreign
thank you very much I have received five
proposals for the resolution to conclude
this debate I can conclude this
discussion the vote will be held
tomorrow
has left the non-attached members and
joins the Epp group as from 5th of
October this year now we'll continue
with the vote
[Applause]
foreign
we now come to the votes
it's called a lengthy vote
so please bear with me and I'd ask for
your support
to ensure that we can get through this
as a